okay so we're going live in three two
one
um okay so the meeting is being as you
can probably see is being uh live
streamed and broadcast uh on our youtube
channel um it is a meeting in public it
is not a public meeting so only those
people that have been registered to
speak will be permitted to do so
at the appropriate time i will call you
forward to one of the two desks in front
of you um
and give you your timings uh et cetera
et cetera we have provided hand gel for
anyone that wants to use it should you
should you wish it's on the end of each
of those tables
okay um some introductions uh if i may
and so to my far right we have our
community services representative sophie
jarrett to my immediate right we have
sue mullins who is our solicitor
i also have a number of uh planning
officers so no particular order they are
erin welleston louise coleman amy flute
paul thompson and my wiener in czech and
we also have paul reed who is our
environmental health officer he is here
to help us out with some questions uh or
potential questions um in the first two
items um and our planning manager is
alice costner alice you have a statement
to make i do thank you chairman my role
is to provide impartial advice and to
assist members in their decision making
thanks
marvelous thank you very much
let's get into the meeting uh agenda
proper so apologies for absence first of
all please sophie thank you chairman we
have apologies from councillors foreman
and councillor rock with councillor adam
as substitute
marvis thank you very much and
disclosures of interest members do we
have any disclosures i'm going to start
with counselor adam
thank you mr sharon um
on item number six d-o-s-c-a-n
21 i'm the joining ward member a member
of the steering committee
uh on that project a long time objector
and i don't think in all the confidence
i can i can join in with that debate so
i'll step away from the table on that
one thank you manny i think i'll
probably have you removed myself so yeah
that's fine uh council mills
thanks mr chairman um
on
[Music]
item seven on the agenda that's um 21
stroke zero three seven six three stroke
if you will um i'm known to the
applicants the applicant um
lives on my award at lighthorn but um
i have no dealings with this and i'm not
spoken to about it so i feel i can stay
on the committee
yeah yeah no problem thank you thank you
very much um just uh while we're on that
one that like same item um uh one of the
speakers in uh and applicants um i've
met that had an application in my ward
uh but this is new to me i'm here with
no mind as well so just for transparency
we have met but um i'm here with no mine
uh councillor jennings respect
all right
um i'm very sure i probably should make
a declaration it's not item six again
i'm jason ward member but i've not made
any comment and we'll be approaching
with an open mind
marvelous thank you very much cancer
kendall
thank you chairman uh on item eight uh
that's two two slash zero zero seven one
five slash ful uh i'm the ward member
and i'm a member of the parish council
as well but i abstained from the parish
council vote i come to this with an open
mind i should also say that i am known
to the applicant i taught his son about
five years ago
lovely thank you very much any other
disclosures of interest before we move
on sorry council curtin
um
sorry
item um
number seven beaconwood 210373.63
i'm the adjacent ward member and i'm a
member of the tower council planning
which has objected so should i remove
myself from the debate on that um i
presume you took a vote on the town
council yes yes in that case i will ask
you to
remove yourself at the appropriate time
thank you very much um okay any other
disclosures before we move on
no okay next item is minutes now um we
aren't gonna uh approve those minutes
tonight purely on the basis that um
there has been an issue raised uh about
those prior to the meeting that does
need um some
investigation and guidance before we can
move forward with it so we will hold
those over to our next meeting which
means we can go straight into our first
application which is application 2103162
and very that is nemo raceway in a night
cut and our presentation officer is erin
weatherston aaron over to you thank you
chairman
the application site lies to the west of
nightcoats settlement in the countryside
i've identified by the black dot on this
plan just here the m40 is visible on
this slide located just to the south
west of the site shown in blue
to the west of the site lies
replanted ancient woodland known as
itchington halt located just here
neighboring dwellings lie to the north
west of the site west of the site and
eastern night coat settlement
the river rich and ssi lies to the east
of the site approximately in this
location about two kilometers away from
the site at its closest point no
watercourse is located in close
proximity to the site as well there are
a number of grade two listed buildings
within nightcoat settlements and to the
north of the site including the old town
farmhouse which you can see just here
and holmes house which is just here
this slide shows the application site
outlined in red the land comprises of a
parcel of land accessed from light coat
bottom lanes the south just here
the land was granted temporary plant
permission in 2006 reference zero six
forward slash zero zero five four zero
ful to be used for the racing of model
cars in 2009 planning permission was
granted for the use of the land on a
permanent basis for the racing or other
running of radio-controlled model cars
and for no other purpose and this was
limited by condition one of that
permission
this application seeks to vary condition
one of the 2009 planning permission to
allow for camping in the form of tents
and caravans with 14 pitches associated
with the existing law for use on the
land this application is retrospective
and a breach of condition notice was
issued in june 2021 if planning
permission is granted for this
application it will supersede the notice
this slide shows an aerial image of the
approximate location of site outlines in
red just here the site is surrounded by
countryside on three sides and you can
see the m40 just here and the wider
context of the application site to the
south of the site you can see the burton
dassett hills located just here
this application relates to the use of
the land only and no associated
infrastructure planning for application
21 forward slash zero three three seven
eight full is also being considered by
members this evening and relates to
other works and stretches these
applications can be considered
independently from one another
this slide shows for information whether
likely camping and caravaning pictures
are going to be cited along the southern
and the eastern boundary and a planning
condition is recommended in relation to
this application to secure those details
if planning permission is granted
this
council andrew serafin could you stop
clicking your pen please
i know you are watching intently and
listening but it's a little frustrating
sorry aaron do carry on this lighter is
a photograph taken from nightcoat bottom
lane looking west towards the
application site the red arrow shows the
approximate location of the site
this slide shows several photographs
taken from the rose the largest image
just here to the left of the slide was
taken looking into the site from the
access gate you can see just here the
top right image was taken looking along
the road with a southern boundary of the
site visible just to the left of the
image here and the final photograph on
this slide was taken looking in the
opposite direction so you can see the
hedgerow boundaries in the road that
connects to the application site
this slide shows a number of photographs
taken from within the application site
and you can see just close to the
eastern boundary so the top right top
left photograph shows eastern boundary
just here
just panning around you can see the race
track just located here
the next image was taken looking along
the northern boundaries it's a northern
boundary the site here towards the
western boundary you see just here
the bottom left image was taken looking
towards the rostrum and the racetrack
you can see just here with the western
boundary
you can see the vegetation along that
boundary just there and the final
photograph was taken panning around so
you've got the eastern boundary just
here the western boundary you can see
the rostrum and the racetrack in the
center with the grass creek road you can
see just here along the eastern boundary
this photograph was taken from within
the application site looking south
you've got the southern boundary just
here you see the access air onto the
road and the eastern boundary just here
and this photograph was taken looking
across the application site from the
southern part of the site looking north
you can see the eastern boundary just
here
the racetrack in the center the rostrum
and the plastic building here and
the access just going along the western
boundary
this slide also shows the access to the
north
and there is agricultural land to the
north of the site which the applicant
has put forward as a full back position
in this case
there are a number of updates this
application which have been circulated
on the update sheet there are also a
couple of verbal updates for this
application one is that we've received a
further representation this afternoon
but no new planning material
considerations were raised the second
update is i apologize there was an error
in the report in relation to the
highways comments that we've received
but we have received updated highways
comments this afternoon that raised no
objection subject to conditions which
have already been recommended by offices
it's recommended a grant planning
permission subject to the conditions and
notes outlined within the officer report
and on the update sheet thank you
erin thank you very much indeed let's
have our first speaker of the evening
who is councillor trezler of bishop's
itchington parish council
councillor treasurer good evening and
welcome pick a desk whichever you prefer
now if you press the button in the
middle of the microphone it'll turn red
and that means it's active we can hear
you you'll have three minutes i'll give
you 30 second warning for your time is
up and if you could stay seated for
questions afterwards that'd be great
otherwise whenever you're ready it's
over to you good evening all um as
you've kindly said i represent bishop
stitchington parish council steve
tressler parish councillor
we have consistently objected to the
proposals
and what i'm going to do is shortly just
explain the objections
that we see in a succinct way as i can
this is a written statement so i
apologize for its detail and lack of
perhaps the
personality
firstly the condition
caravans and camping
the condition being varied precluded
camping
the site has been camped on extensively
since then so any conditioning
henceforth needs to be enforced
effectively
the condition proposed that 14
is an appropriate number of pitches it
should be clarified in wording of
condition 2 that this is 14 in total
regardless of the type tent caravan or
motorhome
further the planning statements proposed
that on average around 20 competitors
camp
for the following day suggesting that
even without the likely intensification
of activity on the side there is
potential for the condition to be
breached
unfortunately owing to extensive and
apparently zealous reaction
of information large proportions of
information submitted in relation to the
application by parties on all sides
has been withheld
entire pages in some cases
this may have held vital information on
shifting the balance to either direction
may i have three minutes for the next
section
i'm afraid you have three minutes in
total okay
you've had one minute 39 so far just so
you know okay retro
for facilities they've already been
built
the recommendation here also depends
heavily on the imposition of planning
conditions
the reason we are here today is to
retrospectively consider the changes
made by the applicant
which would done without regard to the
extinct
conditions of planning permission
we disagree with some of the policy
assertions made with respect to both the
core strategy and the bishop digital ndp
for as10 to support this development
which is not covered by the specific
policy in the court strategy
it would need to offer significant
benefits to the local area
however there is no evidence of this
offered and the operator is registered
in wokingham
if as10 cannot be met then neither can
bin dp1 new development within richard
titchington or ba bin
dp3 local economy the emerging bi ni ndp
as the site is we held
with is without the buap 30 seconds
cs24 seeks the same amount of things and
is also
unsatisfied due to the impact of
character lack of benefit to local
communities the site being accessible
only by private motor vehicle
wcc ecology local residents and
representatives have highlighted the use
of oil
wcc ecology local residence represents
in one case 2000 liters are added to the
track having a similar treatment
approximately a month before cancer
tesla i'm afraid your time is up on this
item so i'm going to have to ask you to
wrap up quickly
that is actually planned for this
weekend
to highlight the points everyone will
make this evening
at the end of the day i think it is very
important you see what is being verbally
communicated this evening thank you very
much you you wouldn't mind staying
seated just for questions if you don't
mind please there may not be any but we
we can explore council crump have you
got one i think you could tell i was
just in them i could yeah
a couple of questions if i may uh first
of all what consultation with yourselves
is the parish council um is the
applicant
done done with you what um have they
consoled
so have they been in consultation with
you regarding this application and have
they come to the next council not at all
okay second right canvas second and
you mentioned the ndp um what status has
the bishop citington ndp scholars of
consultation and his referendum over the
next next period thinking just one
slight follow-up it's to do with the ndp
for this
this type of um application or this area
what
uh did it say in your ndp for this area
of usage was it
shown as brown land and there was an
ecology area where there was um
issues with its usage okay thank you
thank you mr chairman thank you council
crime members have we got any other
questions councillor casa mills thanks
mr um
you're saying it oh good evening by the
way sorry um you said there's no uh
specific benefits the local economy no
no not bringing anything in not at all
okay not with 14 caravans and a limited
usage okay thank you
okay unless there's any more for any
more
[Music]
no council treasurer thank you thank you
sorry i didn't complete but that's right
you i mean we've got the second
application so i'm sure you can get a
chance to say what you want to say
during that thank you very much pleasure
thank you okay um our next speakers are
mr kim salmon um on behalf of lower
springs farm residents to come forward
and grab a seat and we also have um
cynthia bettany
i believe
okay i've got you registered to speak um
it may well be counselors have questions
that you want to answer so if you want
to sit at the front here just in case
you're most welcome to because you are
registered
you don't don't feel obliged to say
anything but you can sit there
you may be able to answer some questions
that we may have otherwise um mr salmon
can can do his thing is this on oh yeah
it is on and loud and clear you'll have
three minutes thank you i'll give you a
30 second one before your time is up
otherwise whenever you're ready it's
over to you okay thank you um my name's
kim sam and i'm speaking on behalf of
the residents of bishop he's in north
end knight co and burton dassett
and the objection to both of these
applications
um i'd like to thank the the committee
for the opportunity to speak and
contribute
um i should like to commence uh with the
planning approval of oh nine
forward slash zero zero six seven five
uh forward slash full 2009
which sets the scene for this
um the description submitted for the
development
for that development and the supporting
information refers to a hobby club
and
we're advised that this was not
adequately supported by concise
conditions
this
was then a restriction to enable
enforcement action um other than camping
um a legal letter uh was sent to st sdc
from field fisher that challenged this
premise
uh consequently insufficient
restrictions and conditions have allowed
unintended ex
ex
of the site
since march 2000 so it's been completely
exploited
at the detriment of residents the local
community wildlife and the countryside
setting
construction and engineering works
undertaken has fundamentally changed the
scale and intensification of events
being held
the unintended consequences has changed
hobby club to a commercial business nemo
racing operating national and
international racing events for
financial remuneration russian and
profit attracting attendances of
multiple hundreds including commercial
vendors catering large-scale camping
multi-day events over weekends and bank
holidays increased frequency of
large-scale racing events and
subsequently
uh and substantially uh different from
the original uh purpose for a small
scale
uh club for people meeting to race their
nitro controlled cars
this site is uh uncontrolled and
requires stringent conditions
there have have been adverse impact on
residents and local community noise
nuisance from constant high pitch of 15
nitro racing cars and a pa duration and
frequency of events every bank holiday
and week motor most weekends extensive
camping and associated camping vehicles
for an inappropriate site access adding
damage to an old salt lane high numbers
of attendees
unnecessary increase in vehicle
movements using a narrow country lane
and the countryside setting at the foot
of burton dassett hills
the objections from residents parish
councils and ward councillor and others
to
reject both planning applications in
terms of camping reduce the construction
and engineering and track to its
previous scale limit attendance
numbers
numbers of events frequency reduce the
number of consecutive race days reduce
365
826 operating time scales
and limit scale of catering marquees
flags banners and other paraphernalia
and stop the commercial selling of goods
there is a series of un and also
unrecognized collateral damage mr salmon
i'm afraid that is your time i'm going
to have to ask you to wrap up if you can
just a couple of seconds so in summary
the site has
developed to an ex exceptional problem
and
emanating from maximum exploitation of
the consequences of 2009 planning
application and without understanding
the consequences upon the residents and
the local community
and without approved planning permission
it's imperative the permissions for the
continued use of this site are robustly
supported with resilient conditions and
enforceable conditions to ensure
that there are no opportunities to
exploit anomalies and loopholes
thank you very much members do we have
any questions for either of our two
representatives in front of us can't
smell as you do council emails first
thank you mr chairman and good evening
um good evening
it's about the noise um has this been uh
have you had a reading done on the noise
at all
stratfor district council and to talk
some noise monitoring
um and i have written back to them on
this matter
um on one day that uh
has been undertaken was on a thursday
they don't race on a thursday
and the second event
was a contained event because of
flooding
and
had
racing for electric
units
as well as nitro so
it was it was a contained event and
finished at two o'clock it's not
representative of a three
uh three and four day scale racing event
with hundreds of multiple uh hundreds of
people attending and
all-day racing with 15 cars going around
the track
thank you very much
councillor curtis did i see you stick a
hand up if you've got a question
i don't want to please no no thank you
thank you um i was going to ask about
the numbers but you said 100 numbers
attending these events you said hundreds
multiple hundreds and um
in terms of that's in terms of
participants spectators support teams
vendors catering
and on these three to four day events
roughly what is the start and finish
time
the start and finish time is as for
the uh the conditions that are in the
2009 application
they can start at eight although they
arrive at seven
and finish at six thank you thank you
okay any other questions that members
may have customers you've got another
one i think um
okay can this be
seen from burton desert hills i'm not
probably in part yes in part it can
yeah you can can be seen at night
technically i should ask you to put your
microphone on when you're answering that
because the members of the public that
are watching online won't be able to
hear you and i'm sure they'd love to so
could you repeat what you said please
okay yes
we're on
it's a horizontal surface so no we can't
see it but we can hear the nitro cars
when they're racing on a saturday sunday
or when whatever day it is
and we can sometimes see them on
practice days as well
thanks cynthia thank you
castle flaming
um you say that they start at eight in
the morning and finish at six at night
how many actual races during the course
of the day is it something where you
know the races are every half an hour or
every 20 minutes it's full on
it's full on all day long all day all
day long and if you're sitting in in in
the the back of a garden or whatever and
they've got the pa system on you know
all the right all the people that are
racing their times
right okay thank you very much just to
get a feel for how much it's compacted
plus it's very visual in terms of all
the camping that's taken place in the in
the field that's adjoining
okay thank you council kendall thank you
good evening um
obviously the application before us is
specifically for the uh for camping and
caravan use uh and things you've
mentioned so far more to do with the
operation of the site as a racing hobby
club
what sort of uh
concerns do you have about the camping
element of this application well this is
covering two planning applications
we're just looking at the first which is
the variation for the camping um okay so
if i rephrase do you have any concerns
about the camping i do yeah can you
about the camping yes yeah well
one what's the need to camp on the site
in the first place when there are
there's adequate provisions but in close
vicinity of the area
2.8 miles
you're taking business away from a
bonified business already established
why is there a need that you saying 14
spaces for camping the majority of
people that will camp will camp under
permitted conditions in the development
in the field they might be camping on
the site
and strangely that field i understand
that the the
the landowner
maybe uh
you know i'd have to check the facts
with this are part of the natural
natural english stewardship i don't
understand why camping would be allowed
on such a such a site
okay thank you
thank you very much do we have any other
questions members council adam
thanks
understand that the um the site has
already started doing this so this part
at least part retrospective um
can you
elaborate on how
the impact yourselves has changed over
time from when from before from the
original application to how it is now
that they've
so that so
the original application was in 2009
um the site is laid dormant until
developed from march 2020
um with all the constructions that are
way in excess
of uh what was a as part of the original
planning commission the track is
completely fundamentally changed where
it was a topographical uh site you know
following the contours is a completely
new track just been relayed in order to
house and hold international events
a scale of the number of people that are
going there is is vastly different
substantially different to anything that
was happening there before
transforming last one
um is that the infrastructure there to
support these extra camping spaces
you know i mean obviously toilet blocks
wash facilities and those sort of things
no no
okay they all take care of themselves in
their own caravans and camper vans okay
and they they they
erect extra
portaloos which often get delivered to
lower spring farm by the way okay thank
you
castle jennings
last one
you mentioned that there was somewhere
2.8 miles away is that a campsite it's a
campsite
there are a number of campsites in a in
a very short
proximity to
the site but 2.8 is the closest
thank you
okay lovely
both of you mr salmon and um this is
bethany thank you very much for your
time contribution this evening
okay we'll move to our next speaker
actually i have mr hazelwood who's our
applicant um you're not registered you
are registered to speak but i have a
note here saying that you you're only
here to answer questions you do of
course have an opportunity to speak
should you wish and you have six minutes
to do it so if you want to please do
come forward to one of these it's worth
you doing that anyway just to sit there
in case there are any questions have you
got anything you'd like to say as i say
you've got six minutes to do so if
you've got anything you've you well i
think there's there's
so much
lie in what we've just heard that i
don't think i could do it justice so i'm
here to answer questions for you guys um
obviously the site has been used for
racing patrol cars since 2006 or seven
got the planning as you've outlined
earlier on or your colleague outlined
earlier on um i personally as a younger
boy
attended those races which were national
races absolutely identical in terms of
format to what we do now no different
whatsoever same in numbers as well so
there's so much that's wrong about uh
what this gentleman has just said um i
have to deal in fact and i'm i'm not
going to get drawn into just complete
lies the site is not about is not
visible from their house
we've had four noise reports done um
we've had various offers from yourselves
come out for three of those at an
independent one which was done all day
over a competition from set down for
people like putting up the tents to the
end of the day as well
um which went into the council that was
a request of yourselves that i paid for
um so i
can carry on the toilet supported
toilets we have a contract with the
company they know exactly where they are
so they don't get delivered to his house
they come and service them once a week
i was just scribbled some stuff down
here as i was going along um
we've had three events this year we've
had two one day races and then we had
one at easter that was our last race
and we're due to have a race this
weekend as uh gentlemen pointed out
which are all welcome to come down and
see what we do i think we have 56
participants at that race um we've made
the site look nice we've put flags up
and made it look a fun hobby this is a
family hobby that we do we're not
silverstone we're not racing formula one
cars these are ready control cars
um designed for
anyone to come and enjoy from six years
up to you know pensioners we have the
whole lot our members and we race them
all through the country and there's a
whole national federation for it
um we can put all of those other races
that we go to without any other
restrictions at all so
you know if we have to get to a point
where we we look further at defending
what we do then we'll have some good
help as i say there's a governing body
that is designed to help this racing i
guess it's true we do have international
races that we go and support ourselves
as well as i say i've done it since i'm
a young kid so um
this we're not the big bad wolf here
this is ready to control car racing
families come along and have a jolly
good time
i'll be that as well within your six
minutes um if you want to stay seated
can i just check make sure your
microphone is on there is a red light
yeah yeah yeah i i it sounded like you
were coming through but i couldn't see
the light from here but that's fine um i
think castle jennings has a question for
you cancer journey
i think come on yeah
um yeah whereabouts uh on
your visitors i presume that then
national they come from all over the
country they do yep um and do they ever
have problems finding accommodation
um nobody we've got good uh hotel
infrastructure and it's a point i should
have also made we put in a lot into the
local economy it's about a hundred
pounds a day per participant that comes
into the local economy from
local pubs in gaydon to the fish and
chip shop and bishops itchington
um to the b and b's airbnbs you know
these people come and spend money in our
district so to say that we add nothing
into the economy is absolutely ludicrous
um
it's absolutely not the
case thank you thank you very much
councillor crump
hi
hi hello mr hazel um a couple of things
in the report um condition six the
planning permission of the one going
back to 2009. yeah it says required
parking provision for 30 cars to be
permanently retained from the site at
all times
um
according to the anecdotes i'll be
trying to be delicate we say this sure
you have potentially significant amount
of people turning up correct um
obviously and again looking at the
report there isn't
any it's not on a bus route shall we say
have you got sufficient parking on site
to cater for all the uh yeah absolutely
so um we've got well over 100 spaces for
car park
if we needed to to use so um our races
uh almost always kept on entry anyway um
and so the the wild figures of the
amount of people that are in the field
are just ludicrous because you wouldn't
be able to fit that in
most of what and and just again a
follow-up
um
on page 18 and 19 in the report there
are some conditions
that have been recommended by the
officer
regarding the number of caravans limited
etc
has the officer spoken to you about
those conditions and are you in
agreement with that
i think it's workable for us on on those
numbers um we actually only need to camp
for probably five or six races of a year
uh as i say we've camped once this year
which was at easter um one of the
conditions in there that is slightly
more difficult for us is there's a
provision where it's um only for two
days and one of our races at east is
easter which is four days i haven't had
the opportunity to express that yet my
planning
uh lady that's been helping me with this
this has been going on for two years now
uh is unfortunately not available this
week so i haven't had a chance to catch
up with her to feedback my thoughts on
it
and one final question obviously
you've touched on that one of the
conditions might not be workable
um
part of this has come about because of
retrospective or some
alleged breach of conditions
is that right aaron
as
yes
could i answer on that can i just you
just think so i just would like some
reassurance that
obviously we've had some potential
breaches or
regulation of the situation through this
report
just i think i think you're stretching
beyond our remit at the minute um we're
obviously having an opportunity to put
appropriate conditions in to be able to
restrict what we believe to be right to
restrict and anything outside of that
doesn't benefit from planning and
therefore is an enforcement issue
i don't want us to stray into saying can
we have reassurance that you're going to
stick to all the conditions we'll know
that from action all right
anyone else got anything
yes i just wanted to actually sorry is
that i don't i want to leave that elaine
if i may counsel henry sarafin please oh
yeah hello um
does the noise from the m40 outweigh the
noise from your
racetrack
so on our site uh at any time of the day
the um you can hear the m4 is audible at
the complainant's house that's the one
that's caused most of these uh issues
for us is considerably more noisable
which our noise report which was a
30-40 page document that detailed all
through the day of a race um also showed
that too okay thank you
council curses
thank you yes
thank you very much i was just wondering
you mentioned there's a national
federation yes um
do they
give guidelines on
how events
um are run on noise levels and so forth
and are you compliant with those perhaps
it might be helpful for the officers to
be able to see those yes it is actually
very regulated and full sets of um
rules to host those races which we call
our national races
um including the formats of the of the
meeting themselves which is what we
obviously run to
and
on on noise levels do those guidelines
so they can give guidelines on that
guidelines in terms of the little
exhausts that that the run the cars they
actually have to be homologated and
reach a certain noise level um which is
done actually throughout europe there's
a european federation and a world
federation as well
and they're continually trying to make
them quieter um as you know it's a it's
a subject that comes up every now and
then um so yes there's no sort of
free-for-all they they have to be below
a certain decibel at a certain distance
otherwise
they've got numbers stamped on them
you're not allowed to race them we have
to do like a technical inspection to
make sure everyone's complying to those
rules
i i'm going to ask a slightly important
question what does alligators mean
homologated it means you have to send in
your product as a manufacturer if you if
you made an exhaust pipe you have to
send it into an independent federation
and then they then test it basically to
make sure that its noise levels are not
above the um required level which i'm
not sure off the top of my head what
that is but and then you get homologated
you get a stamp on your exhaust
basically
okay
thank you that's very helpful
okay members any other questions for our
applicant before we move on
no in that case thank you very much for
your time and contribution
let's move to points of clarification to
our officers
oh i do apologize i did this last week
sorry cancer cattle
impossible to forget your good self
you were hidden so far at the back um
like you know the drill you've got five
minutes i'll give you a 30 second
warning now i have given some slides to
uh erin earlier on i believe they're on
the screen um i was assuming that we're
going to be doing it all as one
um so erin can we stick to slides eight
nine and ten please
thank you and you'll be saying when you
want those changing yes um
it would be helpful i'll do my best good
man whenever you're ready thank you
um mr fellow counselors first lady i'd
like to thank um
aaron for her diligence in addressing
these two applications
um this self-contained site which was
developed during the coveyed spring
shut lockdown
under a considerable amount of work done
by people who did not live locally they
traveled up during lockdown i think it
demonstrates that 10 of the people were
talking about
this application brings no
real economic social or environmental
benefits to stratfor district um erin if
you could move on to the second slide
we are told everybody can everybody use
local um
hotels etc etc
this was the last event they had
there are over 100 vehicles on site that
day
uh there are something like 43 caravans
parked as you can see not on the red
line area but by people attending
uh the site
the reason i parked on that thing at
that field is because they're issued
with a stop notice an enforcement notice
by stratfor district council who told
them
in uh
the summer of 2020 the camping was not
commit permitted on this site
so they just moved over cut out an edge
and moved straight through to there but
i think it's the quantum you need to
understand
how many vehicles we've got there erin
can we move on one further slide
i don't know if you can see the right
hand image but this is taken off
the social media site which demonstrates
that for august
this year the second event they're
holding in august there are 126 entries
if you look at the table on the left
we've heard there were 56 entries which
coincides with the number of parking
spaces but that is the number of
attendees
attending
practices and sessions between
july 2020
and november 21. now there are one or
two events when there are four or two
vehicles there's one of 36 and 40. but
look at the numbers four up the bottom
brac round five
190 entries
um
nemo dirt grand prix
163 entries 134 drivers
look at the end column
and we see repetitive campaign three
three days four days etcetera etcetera
um
if there was a benefit to local economy
and this was in a sustainable site and
really wouldn't have a problem with
camping on this site
but there is a problem
because
what we have seen repeatedly is
significant number of vehicles drivers
cars coming onto the site
uh which is a very royal setting if i
might remind you
uh for those of you who visited it's
next door to the regional centenary
bridal way route which runs along the
night cabotans
that is used by horse riders uh walkers
there are lots of local stables and
cyclists it's underneath
the nationally recognized burton hills
country park for those of you who reckon
visited the site
and who saw the slides earlier on
then you'll recognize it's a very
tranquil site compare that erin if you
can go back two pictures
compare that to what we got on one of
the events last year where we got cars
parked all over the road a local farmer
couldn't get his tractor down there
because the cars parked although the
site is absolutely jam-packed
it isn't 56 people it is considerably
more
therefore if we allow camping to
continue on this site
yes they can go next door which is what
they have done which is a problem
but what we'll be doing is encouraging
what effectively has already been
demonstrated is a very very significant
self-contained playground for people
with with cars it is not the hobby club
that was given permission in 2009
which was which this i spoke at that
committee meeting which was for 30 to 40
local children to drive cars removing
them from the burton hills country park
onto this site
and that's how it remained
uh for
some 12 years
what we now it was acquired in 2020 by
nemo racing a commercial entity not a
hobby club
to run
national and international grand prix
events
if we start
if we give this planning commission then
that we have tight conditions and one of
the key conditions is we've got two
nights only
if you're going to approve this for 14
caravans
it needs to be restricted 14
accessing the site and it needs to be
for two
to fine nights so we don't have one
caravan arriving for thursday and friday
another caravan arriving friday saturday
another saturday sunday and again sunday
monday we need to save for an event it
is two defined nights on saturday and
sunday or friday and saturday and no
more if not it is open to abuse
that's your time now i'm afraid i'm
going to have to actually wrap up i'm
going to assume you have just wrapped up
good dreams
yeah
good man
okay um i'm sorry you have had the
opportunity to speak um and i can't
invite you i can't invite you back or
allow you to shout from the sidelines
i'm afraid
um okay members do you have any
questions for our wall member please
council crump
hello council crystal i didn't forget
yeah
um
just going back to conditions on page 18
and 19. um
i've just wondered what your thoughts
were you've touched on about the two
consecutive nights
uh for the camping
um i just wondered what your thoughts
about the conditions were
it's just worth noting that the
conditions listed on the 18 and 19 are
also the conditions listed on the final
page 26 so they are within the condition
list just for ease if anyone was already
on that page
um
well firstly i know the office has been
working considerably on the conditions
since this document was published a week
ago so i'm not actually up to speed on
what the current conditions proposed are
which makes me feel very uncomfortable
at this stage
but the conditions as printed in the
report uh 14 pictures is what is set out
in the plan
and and there needs to be an absolute
restriction on 14 accessing this site
um
but and it does say two nights
we have again
and i've already said this and it needs
to be absolutely categoric
uh that those two nights are defined
along with the event they are supporting
um
clearly there will be people coming and
going
but what we do not want to have and and
the enforcement side
let's say a caravan arrives on the
thursday
how is that going to be enforced that
that caravan is not still there on the
friday and has not on on the monday
because you'll have 30 or 40 we've
historically had 30 or four caravans on
site
how can we actually identify that all
those caravans
only stayed for two nights so my request
to this committee
is if we have that condition of two
nights
it is said in advance what those two
nights are
and if it is saturday and sunday
then there will be no caravans or
camping equipment
on the thursday friday or the monday and
that will make it very clear from an
enforcement point of view that they are
only there for two nights otherwise
you'll be unenforceable
the condition about um
it only being limited to drivers
um when you have
has been advertised for the end of
august 126 drivers
and you have
14 caravans
how on earth is that going to be
managed
uh if people come with a uncle's aunt
brothers or sisters supporters club what
about the track marshals what about the
stewards what about the the the um
people involved in catering where will
they be staying it says
somewhere in here that it's got to be
limited to those driving
how do we enforce that
so the whole enforcer the whole issue
about the site has from day one
in 2009 being what can be enforced
so
we need to think very carefully and i
haven't seen the latest draft of the
conditions
that we have conditions
that are clear concise
and anybody from the stratfor district
council enforcement team can walk in and
say yes they they're in compliance or no
they're not and having a driver's ticket
to walk in
uh or buying a ticket in advance and
saying you can only come on you've got
to take in advance it does prevent any
locals going on site by the way a number
of locals have tried to get on site
they've been chewed away so there's no
social or environmental benefit to
locals to get in there
let us have a condition that is
absolutely clear and my worry mr
chairman is i think we should have these
these conditions agreed in advance or
published in advance
and therefore would suggest that we
defer the decision on this
until the proper wording is made
available to all
so that we can understand what they are
and whether they are enforceable
it's a difficult one yeah this is so
important
um what we do not want to see is where
we are today
with
retrospective use of this or not
unapproved houston site cancer casket
i'm gonna have to stop you there because
we are straying a long way from the
question i've given you a lot of leeway
there
um
with the conditions we obviously we will
if we make a decision tonight
we can set the conditions tonight so
you'll be able to hear
when we're making those deliberations
and how they fit so you'll have you'll
you'll hear them now um
one thing i will ask you if i may on the
condition 3 which is on page 26 of the
report
at the moment and this is specifically
about camping you were talking about
camping on non-race days
it specifically says limit camping and
caravanning to race events only there
should be no other camping caravanning
within the application application site
i would propose would change when no
racing
racing events to
uh that it will and it will it will read
there shall be no other camping or
caravaning within the application site
on non-racing event days that covers i
think what you were asking for before no
you're not happy with that i'll tell you
why
um because there was an event last
weekend quite a small event but caravans
started turning up um you know the event
was presumably saturday on sunday but
they turned up you know a number of days
before that i understand that so
therefore
um you know yes it's related to the
event over the weekend but actually
it's it's it's before the weekend
council cap let me let me say again very
clearly what i've just said that i
suggest we change that condition so that
it says
application site on non-racing day so
there will be no camping or caravanning
on non-event days that
that's what i've suggested we send it to
change it to
you'd be happy with that
[Music]
that's just that
as long as our lawyer will we'll worry
about that later i'm asking if you're
happy as long as it is restricted and we
have the two night defined nights
limited right okay
um does anyone else have any questions
or can we move to our points for
clarification
okay council kettle thank you very much
well i'll hear from you again in a
moment on the next item let's move to
points of clarification i'm going to ask
you about the condition that i just said
are you comfortable with what i've just
said is enforceable and robust and will
limit any use of that land uh for
camping or caravaning to just race event
days
yes i'm happy with that
marvellous i'm going to propose that we
do that if we decide to go on to uh
grant this does anyone else have any
points of uh clarification they would
like to raise christopher crump first
i think this is for mr reed
from
his license and enforcement
are you happy that the conditions that
are potentially being proposed with a
slight amendment are clear concise and
easily enforceable
i think from an eho point of view from
the actual point of view yes but they're
really not ph conditions no planning
conditions from a planning perspective
alice i'm going to assume given that
they're in our list that you are
comfortable that they are enforceable
and robust yeah absolutely and just to
confirm that they have been through
quite a lot of scrutiny from our
enforcement team to make sure that they
are satisfied that they do a meet the
condition test and be that they are
enforceable from their perspective so
i've got two for the price of one one
from the eight cha and one from funding
so i'm happy that i'm glad to hear it
counselor curtis
no cancer mills
thank you mr chairman um
how close is this to to the house to the
houses
where's the nearest home to this uh
racetrack
so i've just brought up the plans here
and we've got properties just over in
this location and i'll just bring up the
approximate distances now just so we've
got it um
bear with me i'll just find it
so in terms of the approximate distances
from the site so they are approximate
and we've got a distance of
875
over to here
and um 675 approximately to this
location here so that's the distances
that we've got
can
also um
it was mentioned uh i think by cynthia
bettany that um
it can be partially seen from burton
dassett hills
did we look at that
so in the report we have made reference
it may be visible within the wider
landscape from the burton dassett hills
which are down in this location here
they are some distance from the site i
think in the report from the beacon so
we've got something that we can use in
terms of a reference point um i believe
it was
three kilometers and i'll just double
check because the distances are in the
report
so it is on a higher level so you will
get longer distance views of the site
set within the countryside setting and
we have assessed that as officers and
i'm just finding the distance for you
prepare me one second
[Music]
3.4 kilometers at its closest point to
the application site and that's from the
viewpoint within the burton dassett
hills
thank you
thank you anyone else got one before i
throw in one final one
um
erin from the photos that we saw from
cancer kettle the fields are joining uh
this one so behind i think to the north
correct me if i'm wrong um has been used
for uh allocating cam camping
vans and caravans and other bits and
pieces um
is
we're obviously this is outside of this
site so what we're looking at is
regularizing camping on this site but
that wouldn't prevent any additional
camping being applied for either through
temporary event notices or under
permitted development on the uh
surrounding fields is that correct
that's correct so in terms of any land
outside of the application site we're
not considering that this evening any
land can be used for a temporary period
for camping for 28 days subject to a
meeting criteria so that could be the
land to the north and that's the
argument the applicants put forward as
part of this application so just just to
just completely get my head in the right
place all we're looking at is the red
line and realizing what's within that
and the spaces that are being used
within that everything outside of that
is not for our determination tonight
that's correct it's just within the
application side marvelous that's
straightened things out for me thank you
very much indeed right unless there are
any other points of clarification from
our members i will move into the debate
who would like to kick us off councillor
curtis
thank you chair um and just picking up
your final point of clarification there
it seems to me that as you say what
we're looking at tonight
is simply
this application that's before us
and
it
seems to me that most of the
problems that have been
given by residents and the war member
are outside the scope of this
application
and
however we may or may not um sympathize
with those concerns
it doesn't seem to be within the scope
of the application
before us
whatever we may think
thank you
i think that was a very elegant summing
up um
would anyone else like to contribute
towards the debate cancer
dixon thank you chairman as this is a
vary to an application in 09
i think it's a situation whereby if we
try to put ourselves back 209
and the application was for a hobby use
and that application had included
caravan and camping at weekends because
they have events over two nights
would we agree
or
refuse it
if we would refuse it we declined this
application
if we would have agreed it we accept
this variation am i right
you maybe go cross-eyed then trying to
wear that out um
let me put it a slightly different way
from the way you've put it the 2009
application was considered
with what was put in front of them
um
a determination was made and that is the
one that is now being sought to be
varied planning law allows for a
variation we are now looking at a
slightly different application in that
the previous is being varied
we have within our gift tonight to make
a decision on that it happens that it
does include camping and caravanning
does that help
please say yes
okay
marvelous
council crump
um i slightly disagree with councillor
curtis i think
we are in a position that we've got to
make a decision on what we've got in
front of a state in the obviousness but
i wouldn't be the first council
councillor to state the office at a
council meeting particularly at planning
meetings
but particularly on this one
we are trying to regulate this there was
some discrepancy there was some slight
ambiguity there were some things that
need to be regularized so i think
we have got some control
we're talking about the maximum number
of events we're talking about
the planning etc so
if i didn't have the events the maximum
of two events per month
it would be unlikely that people would
be turning up to the temporary license
to the field whichever so i think
we have got some
control it be slightly tacit control
so i think you know slightly disagree
with councillor curtis on there um and i
think
you know we've gone through these
in quite
quite decent detail we've gone through
clarification of the points and the
conditions on page 18 or 21 or whatever
page we want to touch them on and 96
yeah
so on animals there's a few hidden ones
wasn't there lauren erin that you
haven't told us about it yet no any joke
um
so i think i think we've got
you know i think
we've got to a point where we we have
got clear and concise and potentially
enforceable conditions um so i think
slightly disagree with council curtis
that
you know we're only limited in what we
can do but
if we limit what we can do on this site
it will have potentially have a knock-on
effect
on the the temporary
28 days that was mentioned as well
yeah i i think you're agreeing with
cancer curses you're just taking a
little bit further but there we are um
cancer kendall signal next and then
council curtis
i'll be brief i think
on one occasion i completely agree with
council curtis 100 i know i know um look
i think while i do sympathize with the
parish and the neighbors around this
then i fully accept that it probably
does cause
uh disruption every now and again and i
think that disruption is
is probably not pleasant for the locals
but we've got to stick to what is the
remit of this application i'm not seeing
anywhere anywhere else for us to go out
and i think
we are going around in circles a little
bit so if we push this forward i'm happy
to propose that we grant the application
would that include the adjustment to the
condition
yes and of course everything that's in
within the update so there's an
amendment on that as well too yes number
five mr german isn't it appropriate
we're going around in circles vince it's
a racetrack
um i'm gonna second that uh proposal um
i'm sure i'm as shocked as you are that
we're in the agreement with councillor
curtis but
um i i'm gonna second that um council
curtis you indicated
no thank you and i was going to second
councillor kendall i mean and i think
actually
going for approval with this it gives us
more control
and i think that's it we are looking at
the application in front of us we're not
looking at the other issues
and so yeah i'm very happy to go along
yeah i think consideration has been
given to the other issues which has
resulted in
15 what i consider to be extremely
robust conditions to try and regulate uh
some of the frustrations that we've
heard from tonight council jennings you
indicated as well do you still want to
speak no in that case unless anyone else
has anything they want to contribute
towards the debate
we will it's already on uh we will move
into a vote so uh the proposal is to
grant uh application 2103 162 vary at
nemo rateway in night cut
along with the amended condition and the
condition in the update could i please
have show of hands those in favor
unanimous it's not unanimous quite
uh you abstaining so it's all but one
okay
um so committee therefore resolves to
grant application 21.03 162 vary um we
have been going for an hour i certainly
need to come for a break and a little
bit of a breather because that was quite
intense uh two minutes strict two
minutes and we'll be back in okay thank
you very much
okay ladies and gentlemen that is the
straight two minutes uh marginally over
thank you for that indulgence um
we are now back uh and live again so our
next um item this evening is application
21 0 3 3 7 8 ful again at nemo raceway
in at night to and our presidential
conferences once again aaron weatherston
aaron whenever you're ready over to you
thank you
chairman the application site is the
same extent of that considered as part
of the previous application 21 0 3 162
vary it's identified by the black dot on
this plan just here
within the locality we have the m40 just
here itchington holt over here to the
west of the site neighboring dwellings
the northwest of the site
watercourses
and the lane to the south where the
application site has access to a number
of greater listed buildings within
nightcoat settlement and located here
and over here to the east of the site
there's also the river richard sssi
located in this location here
this slide shows the application site
outlined in red comprises comprised of a
parcel of land accessed from existing
vehicle access to the south
planning permission is sought as part of
this application for the regularization
of the site layout structures hard
standing the internal access roads
and other features and this is part
retrospective
this slide shows an aerial image with
the approximate location of a site
outlined in red
you see the context of site with
existing agricultural land the m40 and
the burton dassett hills located to the
south of the site just here
this slide shows a proposed site plan
the elements include a new catering
container located to the northwest of
the site just here a rostrum located to
the west area just here this is got a
covered area above it and has a control
office and storage below
just on the western boundary adjacent to
the racetrack
there's also a proposed
shed just here plastic store
and toilet located on the western
boundary
and a retention of hard standing which
is here located to the west of the
boundary up this section here adjacent
to the race track
a number of internal grass roads are
proposed with grass creek in this
location and heading north to the site
the competitors pit area just located
approximately here on the plan
there are a number of structures within
the application site which don't form
part of this application and they are
located just in this location here and
that includes a nissan hut an iron
building and a caravan and condition 10
seeks their removal as part of this
application
in the center towards the southern part
of the site there are 56 car parking
spaces shown and to the eastern and the
southern boundary 14 camping and caravan
pictures
this slide has proposed elevations of
the toilets plastic shed restroom and
store you can see just here toilets
plastic sheds the store and the rostrum
with a covered roof area and access up
and down on both sides with access
beneath to the race control
to the right hand side of this slide you
see the plastic
shed just here
in this top right image you can see the
caravan that's proposed to be removed by
the conditions and then this sound hurts
which is just here and the bottom right
image you see the rostrum as it is on
site with a cupboard area above and
below you've got the control and the
office
this light has a number of photographs
taken from the access
of the site the first is looking along
nightcote bottoms lane to the west
the top right is looking in an eastern
direction you can see the southern
boundary of the site just here and the
final photograph is taken looking south
looking at the vegetation across the
road from the access point to the site
this slide shows a photograph taken from
within the application site looking
south got the eastern boundary just here
the track to the right hand side and the
grass creek coated along the eastern
boundary of the site
this photograph was taken from within
the application site looking south
across the track you can see here
the rostrum is visible just to the right
of this image and the western boundary
with the hardstand you can see just here
this photograph was taken close to the
western boundary of the site which is
just here at the bottom of the racetrack
looking towards the southern boundary
that you can see just here with the
vegetation and hard standing access
and this final photograph was taken from
the northeastern part of the application
site looking across the site through the
rostrum here the western boundary and
the race track and this is the
competitors area to the north of the
site
there are a number of updates to this
application which have been circulated
on the update sheet there is also one
further verbal update in respect to the
fact we've received a further
representation this afternoon but no new
planning material considerations were
raised it's recommended the planning
permission be granted subject to the
conditions and notes outlined within the
officer report and on the update sheet
thank you
aaron thank you very much indeed okay
let's go to our first speaker on this
side who is councillor dressler from our
bishop station parish council hello and
welcome back
yes
you can so you've got three minutes in
which to take your time and once again
i'll give you 37 in the morning i think
if you remember from earlier i was
talking about various um
i'm going to start with wcc ecology
um
local residents and representative
highlighted the use of oil i think we
got to that last time
in one case 2000 liters were added to
the track
it having had a similar treatment
approximately a month before the
condition required
requiring a management schedule
and seems the approval of dumping of
this oil it source unknown rather than
taking more direct action to tackle what
has been identified as an ecological
problem
the track service appears to have had
some sort of matting overlaid since
purpose material and ecological
consequence is also unknown highways
response as assessed
response has assessed the site as having
12 camping pitches it is 14 however more
concerning is that they still have
concerns
that if the use of the site is expanded
it could further increase vehicle
movements and impact the adjoining
highway the proposal is an
intensification verse that currently
permitted
as the parking spaces increased from 30
to 56 plus a further 14 camping pitches
taking total vehicles from 30 to 70.
the proposed changes to the site are to
make it more attractive and therefore an
intensification of its use
to the proposer's objective
at its current use there is already a
significant parking overspill which
we've seen earlier into the carriageway
and verges of a single track lane used
by a variety
of vulnerable road users
this intensification of the site's use
facilitated by the changes
retrospectively proposed here has
brought increased quantity duration and
frequency of noise
that has been described locally as a
sound of angry wasps having a stream of
fight
questioning the assertion that it's
supported by any policies which are
dependent on the development having an
acceptable impact on the landscape's
character guess what i finished
i didn't even need to give you 30 second
warning top man thank you very much
members do we have any questions for
answer tesla
no in that case thank you very much your
time and your patience this evening we
do appreciate it
okay we'll call for our next speaker on
this item who is once again mr kim
salmon
um we do of course have cynthia bethenny
uh should any questions arise cynthia
entirely up to you if you want to come
forward for belts and prices it's
probably best if you do
okay mr salmon again if you want to make
sure your microphone is on uh before you
start speaking but otherwise you'll have
three three minutes almost said 30
minutes then three minutes with a 30
second warning should be good
whenever you're ready it's over to you
well a lot of this again links with the
uh
explanation i gave for
the very for the camping
um the the extensification in terms of
the building and construction work and
the engineering work to that site
is way beyond what the original planning
and obviously they're submitting this
retrospectively because they've already
undertaken the work
then i'm further work to the track um in
order to meet the standards of uh
of um the brca i think it's called uh
for remote uh controlled cars
uh in order to
um
hold national and international events
and
have
a large scale events at that site
um
the
the reference i think has been made uh
to about oil vegetable oil is just as
bad as a pollutant as fossil fuel
and tendering district council issued a
document um a little while ago about oil
ingress into
the water courses
and which takes out oxygen
and affects aquatic uh wildlife
there's no consideration being given to
that the site is on a flood plain
and and regularly floods
um
the the
the number of
of uh
attendees to that site
um are attracted because of the
improvements and exploitation of that
site
in order to attract uh the premium
events and to hold international and
national events
you know so
holding
uh
and having appropriate conditions in
order to
restrict the numbers on the site
restrict the number of events
restrict the consecutive number of
events
as all
appropriate conditions in order to
protect the local residents and the
environment
and the local community
i can assume at that point you are
you're done you do still have 55 seconds
but don't feel that you need to fill
this i understand i understand the legal
legally that you know people can just
build things and then do retrospective
planning commission permission but this
site has been
you know predetermined for exploitation
for financial and commercial use you
know
why
are we having loads of vendors selling
commercial wares on the site
and services why are we having large
catering vehicles on the site
you know there are multiple hundreds of
people that attend this site
you know irrespective of
what
the owner says
i think your point has been made um and
we thank you for it and notice um
members do we have any questions for
either our speakers in front of us now
please
no in that case both you thank you very
much your time and contribution this
evening and your patience as well
okay mr
sorry i thought i'd turn myself off
there mr hazelwood if you want to come
up again um uh once again you have six
minutes if you want to speak for as much
or as little of those six minutes as you
like and then we'll have questions as
well so whenever you're ready it's over
to you okay i'll keep it brief as well
um
just getting some inaccuracies uh we've
always had uh national events in that
site since uh early 2000s and then when
it was originally um granted it's
planning commissions there's been no
change of
size of events it's always been
a national event and they're capped on
numbers um the over development of the
site it's a shipping container that we
put some green cladding on um so it's
mobile anyway um it's just there's no
foundations or anything on anything
there the toilets are poor to lose they
get taken away
the shed is a ketter plastic shed um
again which
has no foundation or anything on it as
well so
um it's actually
apart from taking down a dilapidated
rostrum and replacing it with something
that was actually safe for people to
stand on that has all of the same
facilities as it did do
back in 2008 2009
we
don't use vegetable oil anymore uh it
was a pure brand new vegetable oil that
was used on the track
so
but with that stopped
now has a matting that's just pegged
into the ground which keeps the soil in
good condition see the cars running on
it tends to churn them up
um so it's all to just to keep the dust
down and make it a nicer place to be
that those issues are now gone anyway um
because i'm matting down
um
[Music]
yeah
i'm slightly lost for words because i i
hear what are actually
lies i'm taking from your own counselor
mr keto and we we have
cctv on our site so if we wanted to
actually have a look and see whether
we're parking out on roads and all these
other wonderful stories that i've heard
there was one instance when we very
first opened and it caught us off guard
where we had a couple of cars out on the
roadway and it was on the road it was on
the verge so it was completely clear
and actually i subsequently paid to have
an attendant on the gates at every
single event that we did during covert
so i i'm as true as i sit here now
there's never been another car outside
our bounds ever
because we have somebody there to do it
um
the list just goes on and on and on um
the victatious nature that we first
received from the council was quite
shocking in the beginning uh i was
ordered or given a an asbo letter which
i've subsequently been told to ignore
from the council nobody even came down
to see me
obviously the complainant is connected
with the council or was connected with
um your ex chief and yeah we've been
bullied basically and i'm sure they
thought we were just going to roll over
and they picked the wrong person's role
over because we're doing nothing wrong
we're using the land for what we have
planning for anyway
and we're trying to provide something
nice for the local community to come and
use so on one hand we have
your colleague telling us that there's
absolutely nothing coming into the local
community
we had 30 caravans and we have 160
entrants by the way that's just because
he doesn't understand how the system
works there's multiple classes so you
have
electric cars nitro cars and truck cars
and you can enter multiple classes so
that's why some of those numbers look
quite high that's actually not the
amount of people that are on site
[Music]
i'm gambling because i'm trying to
remember all of the
the lies that uh to go through um but
anyway at its core i think we have a
great family hobby for people to come
and enjoy
thank you i'm just going to make this
point now that we as a committee are not
here to determine who isn't and is it
isn't isn't telling the truth
um
whilst
we understand frustrations from both
your perspective and also the members
that have spoken before yes we're not
here to determine that we're here to
determine a planning application yeah
within planning law and planning policy
okay and that's as much a reminder for
the members of this committee that
that's what we're basing this on
not
hearsay and we have to work on evidence
understood members do we have any
questions mistakes with council club
thank you mr chairman yeah i'm slightly
unhappy with the term lies i think
different interpretations of the facts
and things like that might be a better
phrase or
um
firstly i've got a point about flooding
um
just be interesting to see how you think
you'll be able to um i know this is a
condition as well
how are you about to manage the flooding
because i think you mentioned it and
it's been mentioned in the report there
was some events that have been cancelled
by yeah so yeah absolutely so if if the
weather's looking bad or it's looking uh
like it's going to be
tricky weather then we do cancel the
events has been pointed out before so we
just don't have anybody uh come along to
them
so you think you'll be able to
so you basically cancel rather than yeah
okay that's fine and
there's been some slight
disagreement regarding community access
to the event yeah obviously you just
mentioned you're encouraging them yeah
um others have said something different
can you just indicate absolutely i'd
love i'd love to clarify that so our
first meetings were actually classed as
a sport and so our first meetings were
held during some of the coveted um
restrictions whereby sporting events
were allowed to take place again where
the the hobby that we do is actually
part of the motorsports federation msa
which allowed us to have limited number
events but it meant that we couldn't
have any general public come into those
so at those events we had to have a
steward on the gates to make sure that
nobody that wasn't registered
could come in
as soon as those restrictions were
removed it's absolutely welcome to
everybody and we have
multiple people in local communities
that have joined us as members to come
and use the tracks with all sorts of
different uh model cars basically you
can come and use anything that that you
have you don't have to have one of our
competition cars you can come with
something that you bought down your
local hobby shop
and
spectators
yep again
they were not allowed during covid so
most of our races were actually held
during times where there was some
restrictions so we couldn't have
spectators we had to provide a list of
each
participant to msa that was part of the
criteria of being able to put the events
on
and i think
unfortunately we we didn't have the
opportunity to convey that to some of
our um complainants to understand that's
how or why we were doing races um but
absolutely spectators
would be welcomed however
it's really not got that wider appeal um
so you know all of this year that's you
could come and um spectate there's no
charge for spectating um but we we tend
to not really we're not very well known
so we don't tend to get very many
spectators
counselor adam next please thank you um
do you do you recognize the the photos
that counselor kessel put up before
would you say that's a typical
representation of the attendance no i
wouldn't say it's typical i recognize
the photos i know where they were taking
which was when we were you know first
one of our first races that we did
um the one from this last weekend
would be a a fairly typical race that
was actually a national event so that
was one of our very biggest ones um our
club races that if you like our more
regional ones are a fair bit smaller
they're normally over one day and so
they don't have any camping at them
council candle
thank you chairman uh my question's a
bit uh on the ecology matter i just want
a bit more clarity if that's okay
obviously the county ecologist picked up
on the use of vegetable oil
i'd like to understand from what you've
explained that was when the track had
the sort of earth layout that's right
that's what it is
correct yes fine thank you
okay any other questions for our
applicant
no in that case thank you very much your
time and contribution this evening
thanks for your patience
now i'm sure there's someone i've got to
invite down this time
councillor kettle
he would argue the most important
speaker of the evening
uh cancer careful once again you'll have
five minutes with a 30 second warning uh
whenever you're ready and settled you
may start
um thanks mr chairman if we just have
the slides up erin starting number one
uh can we stop when the slide comes up
please
um it's not very clear but that's a
google earth picture in 2017
of the site grass grass grass and
everywhere you can see his grass
um none of the locals ever saw events
taking place because nothing really
happened there it was very quiet it was
designed for a local club with children
using their kit brand but there were
with the where adults on tenders can we
move on one side
we have a gentleman there sitting on a
pot and we have a single loo
as you can see the track is is still
grass
we then move on to the third slide
those are pictures off the nemo website
in um one in the snow
um two of the snow actually and one with
the new layout
uh the grass has all disappeared
uh the grassed area between and around
the track is now plastic grass
the original grass has disappeared
so what we've seen is a transformation
of this site from a local hobby club to
an organization that has now signed up
to the international grand prix circuit
and this weekend they are proposing to
have the first british grand prix
international grand prix here
uh which is the fourth in a series of
five i think i'm correct the states
might want to correct me on that
um
but
what we're what we're talking about is
something which is fundamentally
different this isn't a fallback position
this is a new activity it is a
commercial activity it is no longer a
hobby
residents of take take legal advice and
um erin
you were fortunate a letter this
afternoon by um
one of the previous speakers which was
the legal advice received from field
fisher
which in field fischer's and there's a
planning law planning lawyer not a
normal lawyer you might say that
clearly sets out that this is a
fundamental change and therefore we need
to look at it as a new application not
as an extension of the previous
application i'm not a lawyer but when
you've got a planning lawyer writing
that i have to take their advice
so what we need to understand
is if we are starting with a new
application
what conditions would we put
on something of this scale
where you've got international and
national events
taking place
in my world it's slightly uh between a
local children's football club
and somebody trying to join a league or
playing in the league or for those of
you in the racing or horse world
uh a little children's gymkhana in the
field compared to stratford or warwick
races it is a completely different
league would we apply conditions
to the latter which would not be
relevant to the former
and my issue here is yes there is
permission to drive small cars remote
control around a bit of grass track
that is very different from a pre-made
and we now know a matted surface
uh with all the the extra bits have been
added to it
um the original rostrum was a wooden
rostrum which this planning committee
in 2009 restricted its height
to have the minimum impact on the
landscape we talked about landscape
earlier on this evening instead without
permission
a large container was moved in and if we
move in um so i'm going to move on some
pictures one more
so that's the sort of infrastructure
that's gone into the ground
we've got flooding areas there we've got
a track which is mostly
road planings around the outside or
appear to be
if we then go on
we talked about flooding yes it does
flood it floods really seriously um
roger thatcher the former enforcement
officer got stopped trying to get out of
there because it was flooded if we move
on though erin one couple more
we have a control room one more please
uh we have a control room
um which was not necessary and not
required for children's racing we have
control room with what appeared to be i
don't know what's on the side but it
looks to me like shopping facilities
there
which is again very different from what
we had before so i'm going to come from
in summary is we need to have proper
controls on this site to ensure that we
do not subject locals to events
effectively 365 days a year from 8
o'clock the morning to six o'clock in
the in the evening if you if if this
site designed for kiddies turns into
that sort of operation
it will be a fundamental change to this
very rural network so i'm going to
suggest firstly i'd like to see this is
a temporary commission so we can see it
in operation in all its glory
particularly when you have these big
international events
and whether the car parking which mr
hazelwood says only happen once actually
look at the pictures
uh they've got different skies in them
the cars have been parked regularly on
the verge because um lots of people take
parish council taken photograph i've
seen it uh other local residents have
seen it it has been an issue so let's
have i'd like to suggest this a
temporary condition for 12 months
let's look what happens during those 12
months let us see what the impact is
like but what i'd also like to say is
can we tie in
they've said they have 12 events
let us restrict the number of events and
by condition to 12.
then residents know
when and how long the events are going
to go on for
residents have absolutely clarity as to
what's going on not only residents
but people walking down the footpath
down the the um centenary way this is a
national bridal way by the way
uh it starts somewhere not quite
national it starts in north midlands end
up well down in the south horse riders
you gotta ride a horse when you've got
that's an activity there's bunting
there's that there's um
advertising material flags type stuff
that you see
let us try and see what happens but
let's have conditions that limit the
number of events let's have conditions
that get car parking off the road let's
have conditions that um
yeah sorry let's have those two
conditions for starters and let's make
sure which is absolutely clear for
residents that they know
what their that this new operation
because it is no longer a kiddies club
is put in the same case that you'd have
with stratford race course warrant race
course a rugby fixture where you know
when the events are what's going to
happen and where people are going to put
their cars
thank you very much councillor kettle i
forgot to give you a 30 second warning
but we are just within time
just so
thank god for that um okay members do we
have any questions for councillor kettle
please
no councillor curtis
thank you thank you councillor uh thank
you um
because
you mentioned that um
some uh a letter has been sent from
a solicitor representing some residents
could you just
say again
when that was sent and to whom
and
what
can you give any idea of what the
arguments
put in that were the the letter was sent
to the former head of planning robert
weeks and copied to david buckland uh it
was sent about 12 probably about in fact
i have a copy of it somewhere on i don't
know it's on screen but i'll find it if
i may
uh mr chairman um
hang on
uh which which uh it came from a company
called phil a former lawyer called
fieldfisher who have a specialist
planning department it was sent as an
update
this afternoon
because mr salmon
didn't realize it hadn't been made
available to members
uh it related to enforcement issues
rather than this specific application
but it relates to enforcement of all the
activities that we're currently
considering tonight
um and why there should be enforcement
action against all of them and the
fundamental view was this is
this is a different
a different operation
intensification i'm sorry i'm going to
push just
ask you what does you're entitled to an
intense fine operation and it goes back
to a heart hertfordshire case which is
the
red line version
uh you can increase the number of
uh not activities
journeys it was related to slate quarry
in
hertfordshire um
from they applied 425 and they got to
250 000
and the judge the judge held that that
was exactly the same operation going on
it was just more of it
[Music]
you cannot apply that here because there
was another case which the solicitor
refers to
which says which relates to a motor
cross event
which is much more similar where things
change there were engineering works to
the site
funny enough that's exactly what
happened here which changed the
operation and changed the scale of the
operation so that the original
application for that side had become
fundamentally different now if you track
through all those if you read that case
go through all these cases that all the
elements all those cases here exist here
so we are not there is no fallback
position here which has been mentioned
because the fallback position is for
kiddies club without any of any of this
stuff that we're looking to prove
tonight this is fundamentally different
so as it's a new application in the
views of that lawyer who is a planning
specialist
we have the opportunity to condition
this properly and then and put a limit
on the level of activity
um if you haven't seen the letter i'm
just wondering whether in fact we should
defer this until members of the
committee have seen that letter because
i think it is pretty important
counselor mills
have you remember your question
um
chris the when were these photographs
taken
they were taken last summer
last summer and
all parking obviously a lot parking on
the grass version so we don't know
how many
attendees were there do we on this
the the there was um a visit by
warwickshire police
in the autumn of 2020
who then subsequently had a conversation
with
roger thatcher the former enforcement
officer
and the number of uh i haven't got that
email in front of me but it was in the
hundreds on the site on that day
um
again very different from the little man
sitting on the tub sorry big man person
uh sitting on a tub watching you've
answered the question schedule thank you
very much um do we have any other
questions for our ward member please
cancer fleming
just the question this might even be a
debated thing really but the conditions
and stuff that counselor kettles has
just been sort of suggesting doesn't
that vary with the thing that we are
actually trying to look at this evening
i think that's i think i'm just worrying
that it's i think that's a point of
clarification which we'll get to in a
moment and i'll thank you first unless
anyone who has a question for councillor
cattle can i respond no can't unless
anyone has a question for councillor
kettle um then we will move on
no counsel kevin thank you very much for
your time contribution and your patience
now we are moving into points of
clarification and i believe council
fleming might have a question for us
yeah i'm just
just listening to all the various
suggestions that came through there
if
i just wonder whether we should
disregard some of it because it's
clouding the issue of what we're here to
judge on and
the conditions have been set and if
we're to look at all these other various
conditions um i'm not sure that we can
make a judgment on that based on that
just being sort of sprung on us uh you
know from that perspective so i'm not
sure whether to either take into
consideration what he said or to
disregard him and judge what's what's on
our paperwork
we are
here to work on facts
um and within planning law and what is
what is presented in front of us if you
feel that what counselor kettle has said
will will materially change your
decision making
specifically ask what they might be now
and how they can impact um
or have some consideration to it i've
got a series of questions that might
help you
so let me go through those before i do
does anyone else want to go first
councilor dixon
thank you chair um erin
uh there's a lot of comment regarding
parking on the grass verges on that lane
is there any enforcement that is a
matter of planning regarding that
because essentially this application
seeks more capacity for car parking on
site within the red line therefore
potentially taking cars off the road and
off the verges onto the site
but if we can't have any control
over parking under grass verges either
ourselves the county of the police
because they're not actually obstructing
the highway
is that anything that we should cons
concern ourselves with
other than it's a bit destroying the
grass versions of someone we can
consider the parking within the
application site and that's what the
report goes into
in terms of parking elsewhere we're
looking to recommend a note to advise
obviously there's parking can take place
elsewhere but we've recommended a
highways note just to advise that we're
expecting parking to be within the
application site
council adam
thanks um aaron with the extent
permission uh this is seeking to vary um
can you explain how what the extent of
is allow
what the extent of allowable activities
are under that just because i noticed in
your conclusion that you talk about the
existing business and leisure use but it
appears that that has that's quite a a
range that can
exist under that sort of definition and
obviously the contention with the local
board member is that
this is
larger now than it was allowed for
originally
yes so in terms of the extent planning
permission on the site we've got the
2009 planning permission and let's
extend and that was the basis when we
were looking at this um so in terms of
what can be done we're looking at radio
and controlled cars being used on the
site for no other purpose with a
variation of condition we've considered
this evening that now includes ancillary
camping and caravanning and so that's
the the extent planning permission we
have on the site subject to the
conditions which included things like
landscaping um no additional hard
standing flood lighting and provision of
30 parking spaces within the site and
the hours of operation which is monday
to sunday eight til six so that's the
extent of the
permanent permission and the variation
of condition ties in the same hours of
operation that we've considered this
evening so that's a starting point so
when we're looking at this
application in offices view we've
considered the scaling nature of the
existing business that's on the site so
we have to look at the extent permission
what's lawful on the site and then
consider how that fits in when we're
assessing this and in this case we see
this as an improvement enhancement to
the facilities in terms of the
associated infrastructure um so that's
how we've considered it as a matter of
planning judgment as officers
is that we're looking at just the
infrastructure in this case and the use
was considered as part of the previous
case
follow up on that with regards to the
business then there was there
i mean
originally i understood that the exam
permission was hobby use which
understand to be slightly different from
a business use
albeit that might be semantics um
as there was a um existing enforcement
action of which of the extents i'm not
sure i don't want to open up um is it
fair to say that the business use
of it prior to this application going in
may have been
unacceptable under the previous um
permission
just to clarify in terms of the 09
permission um there's nothing that
limits the number of attendees or the
events per calendar year it's just
within the hours of operation that were
listed and it doesn't restrict the use
on the site to be a non-business use um
it can be a business use it's the use of
the land for radio controlled racing
that the condition refers to an 09
council crump
hopefully you'll be covering it in your
list of multiple questions but i think
my main concern
revolves around the new information
that's potentially coming this afternoon
regarding
um
the letter that's came in regarding you
know obviously one planning solicitor
has got a different opinion potentially
so
that's my main concern about this
whether we're actually
going down the right route
we've got the right legal advice and
we've got the right accurate up-to-date
information
um so hopefully your questions to the
solicitor or whoever you're asking the
questions too we'll cover all those but
that's my main concern on this one
thank you i i did have a list of of
questions that are going into particular
order to get to to take us through the
whole thing council adam has asked two
questions that have covered all of the
questions that i wanted to ask
just to help um with things erin in your
response to cancer adam's questions you
said i believe this is right the 2009
permission
has only restrictions are times of
operation which are 6 a.m that's sorry 8
a.m
don't panic everyone 8 a.m to 6 p.m is
that correct
yes mondays to sundays that is 365 days
of the year there's no limit on how
often so monday to sunday is eight till
six so that's every day of the year
every day um there's no limit on who can
do it or the style that it's done we've
obviously heard it's hobby anyway would
have been pitched as such but there is
no limit on the planning condition to
say this can only be hobbies uh not a
business use so in terms of condition
one which is what's just been varied as
part of the variation of condition um it
shall only be used for the racing or
other running of radio controlled model
cars and for no other purpose and the
variation will include the ancillary
campaign caravanning um so there's
nothing else in there stating that it
shouldn't be a business use it's just
linking it just to the radio controlled
running um on the site
so now obviously we haven't had the
benefit of this legal advice that's been
presented to you this afternoon uh it's
a shame it's coming so late um and we
haven't been able to review it um have
you had an opportunity to read it
yes so we have received that it was as
part of the verbal update a new no new
material planning considerations were
raised and they're all covered in
representation we received a date so the
assertion that we've heard is that this
is an intensification of the site
and that is basically the main crux of
what's going on within that legal
argument and that's my understanding
from what's been presented by councillor
kettle
is that right that is the key to it is
the intensification i've got follow-up
questions to help with that
so in terms of the officer consideration
we have received representations during
the course of the application and they
do make reference to
change of use greater number of events
the scale the intensification of events
and they've been considered as part of
the officer's um
review of the application in our view we
considered that this is for the
operational development only given the
scale and nature and the extent planning
permission on the site so we haven't
looked at this as an identification in
our view we feel it's just the
operational development for an extent
permission so on the basis that it is
operable for
every day of the year between 8am and
6pm
we can't consider it to be an
intensification because in theory there
could be races from 8am to 6pm every day
this is just adding events or these are
just specific events lined up for that
um that's is that a fair assessment
so in terms of the the number of events
this application won't impact the number
of events yes you can do events every
day of the year um it's just facilities
we think are an improvement or
enhancement on the site so all we're
looking at the only thing we're
considering at the moment is uh the
change to the layout of the track
the structures so um
i believe i'm right in saying that there
was a toilet block a caravan
thing at the top left hand if you
wouldn't want yeah there it is top left
hand corner there um
the rostrum i think you uh it's called
uh toilet block and then a couple of
other bits at the bottom and also
removing a caravan and um what looked
like a big rusty tube
i don't care what you called it now um
so we're getting rid of that and then
the grass road around the outside
that's it
yes so in terms of this application what
we're looking at is like you've
described the canteen to the north west
rostrum um the toilet block as well and
plastic sheds and the storage removing
these elements on the western boundary
and then the layout that you can see
there with the retention of the existing
hard standing the grass roads through
the site
and then the condition also includes the
changes to the track that's been updated
as part of the update sheet
if members of this committee determined
that they consider this to be an
intensification and therefore would
apply certain conditions as a result
that is within our gift we would
obviously have to evidence that and and
justify it but that is still within our
gift is that correct
yeah if i can come in on that um whether
there's an intensification is very much
a planning judgment so our view is that
there's not members for you may come to
a different view so you are within your
rights to do that um just obviously
needing to exercise caution in terms of
any conditions limiting use given that
this application doesn't relate to the
use directly and they do have extend
planning permission for a pretty
unrestricted use as you've just gone
through with there in there
marvelous thank you bill has that helped
you with your understanding of what was
put to you earlier
good that's relief
does anyone counsel curtis
thanks chet and
it's just
continuing with this um idea of
intensification or not
although
we understand that basically it's sort
of 80 or 6 365 days of the year
permission
and as that hasn't increased there
perhaps there is an argument the
intensification hasn't increased
but
does not the evident increase in scale
of the events which does seem to be
fairly clear
could that not be then considered to be
an intensify
okay i don't know if that's the debate
or for clarification
we can debate it but i can clarify now
because i ask specifically ask that
question and it's unrestricted so
there is no restriction on that
therefore it's not an intensification
so anyone else got any points
clarification they would like to put now
let's move into the debate who would
like to kick us off
council jennings
in my view it's not an intensification
it's
certainly improvements and enhancements
to the business
uh policy cs24 supports the growth and
improvement of existing attractions
um i don't think we should be
restricting businesses business owners
abilities to improve their business and
make it more successful
businesses they change over the years
and they they adapt some are successful
and grow others fail
um
i think with the amount of people this
brings in as everyone keeps on saying
well that must
they've all got to eat sleep and drink
somewhere i mean that's going to profit
and
benefit the local economy
um
i'm happy to go straight in on this and
suggest that we
approve
go with grant and go with the officer's
recommendation
that is a proposal to grant in line with
the officer's recommendation to be clear
it is and i think we've done extensive
conditions on this and that satisfies me
thank you councillor candle
i won't go on too long um i completely
agree with what's just been said i think
we've looked at this very thoroughly
tonight and i'm very content to second
up the uh proposition
cancer curtis
i just wonder if if we do
go with grant could we
would it be possible i i just don't know
um
looking at council kettle's um concerns
over this to make it a temporary
permission rather than permanent
we it's within our gift um but you would
need to give us a very clear planning
reason as to why you want it to be
temporary
um given i don't know
it crossed my mind that um and given the
discussion we've had about in
intensification etc etc um i'm
struggling to find a planning reason to
justify a temporary
whilst
i don't necessarily disagree with the
two speakers we've just had and i will
be voting in
a similar way
it is worth noting that the
intensification
experienced
has gone up
partly because of restrictions through
the covered pandemic partly because more
stuff's happening
but
there are no restrictions on the site
according to the 2009 um application so
i can't
i can't clearly determine that that
would be an increase in
intensification
as a result of that
if that makes sense counselor adam
yeah i think the the clarification that
we got from the officers cemented it in
my mind that much as there is
contention around this
the planning
permission that they have to is
unrestricted to the large extent of the
things that are contentious that this
doesn't seem to be
the the area of concern almost and
in terms of what they're doing to the
site um and much as i think we all might
be minded to add conditions that's not
within our gift in this in this setting
so um
well
it's within our gift where we have to be
able to justify it with planet exactly i
think that's the one which i think have
been mentioned even if in passing in
terms of say that the time and dates and
whatnot so um although i can appreciate
the community's stance on this i i can't
really see any material planning
condition uh reasons to get into
unfortunately
okay thank you um anyone else have
anything they'd like to say before we
move to a boat
cancer mills
thanks to chairman i'm probably going
against everybody else here i'm just
uncomfortable with this um with this
application we're seeing these
photographs with uh
cars parking on the verges and
it
i just wanted it is going to continue um
i know you can talk about conditions um
let's hope they work but i'm just just
uncomfortable with it mr shannon thank
you
okay thank you very much anyone else for
any more before we move on
no in that case we have a proposal uh to
grant
application 2103378ful
we have a full list of conditions there
are no additional conditions that want
to be applied we of course do of uh have
some further information in the update
sheet so i'm going to assume that we're
proposals including the update sheet
details in that case um we'll have a
vote for those in favor of granting the
application please show now
seven
yep seven seven four against
four four on abstentions
none okay in that case committee results
to grant application twenty one zero
three three seven eight ful and nemo
raceway in night cut
thank you very much everybody for your
time and patience with that let's move
on to our next item
and we will have a change of officer so
while we're doing that i will introduce
the item and hopefully they'll be
settled by then
so the application reference is
discn0076621 that is land at redditch
eastern gateway in bully
our presenting officer will be louise
coleman as soon as she is settled and
ready so louise whenever you're
comfortable and set up it's over to you
apologies louie sorry i'm going to have
to actually start from uh from the
beginning again because
i thought that was on um but it wasn't
so if you wouldn't mind stuff i will
indeed apologize everyone
let's go back okay uh the application
site which is denoted by the black dot
in the center of the plan is located on
the edge of the built-up area of
redditch
the site as outlined in red is allocated
for employment development under
policies red one and red two of the core
strategy
planning permission has been granted on
the site for 32 hectares of employment
land for business and industrial use
the plan on screen shows the approved
parameters plan
the granted planning commission was
subject to a legal agreement in 43
conditions and in resolving to grant
planning permission for the development
committee
removed delegated authority to determine
any condition against any condition
submissions against condition 20.
condition 20 requires the submission and
approval of hgv surveys to demonstrate
the implementation and operation of the
hgb routing strategy
the condition requires the first
hdv survey to be undertaken and the
results submitted to the local planning
authority within the first month of the
first use of any part of any phase of
the development and thereafter on an
annual basis for the lifetime of the
development
reserve masters approval has been
granted for the northern part of the
site and for b8 storage with ancillary
b1 office use and is now occupied by
amazon
the building became operational at the
end of october 2021.
the disk before members seeks the punt
approval for the first hev surveys
following the first use of the amazon
building
the slide here shows the approved hdv
routing map which uh hdbs assess it are
accessing the site need to adhere to and
the location of uh the four
automatic number plate recognition
cameras which capture any breaches
the these are shown
on the prohibited route identified by
the yellow line
the report submitted presents the
results of the first hdv survey
undertaken as i stated on the first
month of the
occupation of the amazon building
from 26th of october 2021 to 25th in
november 2021 and identifies any
breaches within the period
as members will note in your report the
results specify a total of 45 hdbs
associated within the amazon building uh
sorry with them as with the amazon
building recorded
routing via the prohibited route during
the first 30 days
this represents an average of less than
two hdbs per day and the report also
identifies there was a maximum four hdvs
in a single day and there were 10 days
where no breaches were recorded at all
and only one single repeat offender was
captured twice during the same route
the report also note that the building
amazon building was undergoing
construction and fit out works during
the first month of operation
consequently hgvs associated within
these activities are still visiting the
site and therefore affected the results
both warwickshire and worcestershire
highway authorities have been consulted
on the discharge condition application
as has highways england and no
objections are raised
the results for the first month of the
hdb surveys demonstrate the routing
strategy has been operating
satisfactorily and additional measures
have been undertaken by animal center to
further reduce the number of breaches
chairman the recommendation is to part
approve condition 20. thank you chair
louise thank you very much we'll get our
first and only speaker on this item who
is mr andy passmore
good evening sir thank you very much
your patience grab a seat whichever one
you want i think you've got an idea of
the drill three minutes 30 second
warning button in the middle will turn
it red otherwise whenever you're ready
thank you very much for your time
as you'll note from the wording of
condition 20 it was originally intended
that annual hgv surveys would be used to
monitor adherence with the redditch
gateway hgv routing strategy annual
compliance surveys have been standard
transport planning practice in such
situations for many years however the
steering group established by this
planning committee required a more
comprehensive approach given the
potential impact on mappily green and
studly
recent technology advancements have
allowed the provision of a system to not
only match registration plates that site
access with those at key locations on
the highway network but also to use
machine learning to identify whether
matched vehicles are htvs
the manufacturers report the system has
95 accuracy in successfully matching and
classifying vehicles resulting in
continuous monitoring for far superior
to any of the methods traditionally used
the approved system was installed in mid
2021 at a cost of 160 000 pounds and
will have an annual operating cost of
around 25 000 pounds it has been
operating since late october capturing a
total of 242 infringements in the 274
days between the 1st november and the
31st of july this equates to an average
of less than 1 infringement per day
during this time uh there has been on
average circa 300 hcv movements per day
to the building meaning that 97 99.7
percent of htvs are complying with the
hgv strategy and only eight 0.3 percent
are not the tenant is advised of each
infringement with a redacted photograph
of the matched registration plate sent
via email to date no no infringements
have been disputed the tenant has
advised its logistics network of the htv
routing strategy and drivers leaving the
service yard are provided with a leaflet
showing the permitted routes from the
site the benefits of this leaflet are
clear with only 13 of the infringements
occurring upon departure from the site
as non-compliance remains low and well
within the maximum six daily
infringements for stage one management
interventions no escalation has been
recommended at this stage
two sightings of tenant branded htvs
travelling along the privative route
have also been provided by members of
the public the latest on the 20th of
july has been identified by the system
whilst one earlier sighting was not it
should be noted that only hgvs
associated with reddit gateway are
prohibited from routing via the a435
like all other hdvs tenant branded
vehicles not visiting the site are
subject to no routing restrictions
what's not covered by the hgv routine
strategy two sightings of hgvs parked on
it far more lane have also been reported
the tenant has been advised of these and
has undertaken to deal with them however
bwb has recommended that a proportion of
the highway bond secured under the
outline should be used to investigate
and potentially implement measures to
discourage this further it is intended
to discuss this issue with a strategy
review panel when it meets later this
year overall has concluded that the
implemented system provides the
comprehensive monitoring required by the
uh steering group uh and of it and of
attending tenant adherence with the
redditch gateway routine strategy and
today compliance is good
i'm really glad you're on time there
because i was so into what you were
saying i forgot to look at my clock
and that was three minutes and four
seconds four milliseconds so
well done thank you um do we have any
questions for mr passmore
no thank you very much indeed for your
time and contribution this thank you in
that case uh members we have no other
speakers on this item um so does anyone
have any questions for clarification
no let's move to a vote uh oh sorry a
vote
a debate first we'll do that first
council jennings
okay there are no objections from
highways it all seems to be working i'd
like to propose that the planning
manager be authorized to part approve
condition 20.
council kendall
marvelous thank you very much i was
going to second um but i think we're all
there so uh show of hands for those in
favor
that one is unanimous so uh committee
therefore resolves two part approved
condition 20 of hgv surveys uh
as proposed okay let's move on to our
next item um which is application 2103
763 ful uh that is borden hill
our presenting officer is amy flute amy
as soon as you're settled and ready to
go it is over to you
thank you chair
the site donated by the black dot is to
the north of borden hill within a ribbon
of development outside of the identified
build superior boundary for
stratford-upon-avon
the application site edged red is bound
by public footpaths to the north and
west a local wildlife site
is also to the north of the site red
edge neighboring properties are to the
east and there is a garage to the west
planning permission is sought for the
erection of a single story dwelling
landscaping and associated other works
this aerial image shows the site in its
wider context access to the site is from
everson road the site has significant
trees throughout and none of these are
proposed to be removed
the proposed dwelling will be sighted to
the rear of the existing dwelling known
as beacon wood the four bed dwelling is
elongated to um
sorry the four bed welding is elongated
to work with the contours of the land
the plan demonstrates that the building
will be within a landscape setting with
extensive planting proposed the dwelling
will be designed to be negative embodied
carbon in construction and seeks to be
zero carbon in operation
elevations can now be seen which
demonstrate the proposed single story
dwelling
sorry with the exception of the garage
home office projection which will be dug
into the landscape the proposal will use
screw pile foundations to work with the
on-site trees and land contours
the proposal will appear as a series of
pavilions with inner courtyards and flat
roofs to link the pavilions together the
pavilions appear as simple hipped reef
structures clad with cedar shingles to
the walls and roof with local stone
gabions below to screen the piles green
roofs are also proposed to some flat
roofs
and the garage will be um will have
stone gabions as its facing material
this image is taken within the site
looking in a southerly direction beacon
wood can be seen in the distance the
site's western boundary is made up of
mature vegetation
this image is taken within the site
looking in an easterly direction so
down the hill down borden hill and
stratford is in the distance
this image is looking north towards
towards the rear of the site and the
public the public footpath runs along
the bottom within that tree line
[Applause]
and this image is taken from the
boundary with the public footpath to the
north looking back towards the site in a
southerly direction so um you can't see
it in this photo but the actual beacon
were dwelling is is up at the top out of
sight
and now some views into the site from
the public footpaths apologies the
pictures aren't um very clear but i've
tried to
point out where the site is in relation
to the public footpath
chairman it is not considered that the
proposal will result in unacceptable
harm to landscape neighbouring immunity
highways or any other material planning
reasons such as flood risk furthermore
it has been demonstrated that the
proposal and its site-specific design
features would meet the exceptional
design test as prescribed by policy
chairman the recommendation is to grant
the application subject to the
conditions and notes as detailed within
the committee report thank you amy thank
you very much indeed let's call forward
our first speaker besides him who's
counselor
good evening thank you very much your
patience
uh i think again you probably know the
drill by now you'll have three minutes
i'll give you 30 second warning button
in the middle to anyone whenever you're
ready it's over to you
thank you chair uh the show council
opposes to the principle of new
dwellings in this location as it has
done on a number of occasions in the
past as you'll see from the planning
history
the site lies outside the defined
built-up area of the core strategy and
neighborhood plan
it is understood that the district
council can currently demonstrate a
five-year supply of housing land and
therefore the presumption in favor of
sustainable development is as set out in
paragraph 11d of the end ppf does not
apply
and even if the presumption did apply
the proposed development is not in a
sustainable location which means the
future occupiers would be overly reliant
on the private car for access to daily
services and amenities
while the distance from the town centre
may not be excessive to some the very
steep borden hill would render this site
very unattractive for cyclists and
walkers to access such services on a
daily basis
the photos that you saw from the rear of
the public football
um didn't show obviously the the new
proposed building which is much nearer
[Music]
where the
existing building is in the center of
the site is at the back of the site
overlooking the footpath
um it is understood that the applicant
seeks to rely solely on paragraph 80 e
of the nppf and policy h1 of the
neighborhood plan
in order sorry in respect to the
proposal being
truly outstanding and of an exceptional
quality in order to gain favor this is a
very high bar set in the national and
local policy planning policy
the energy efficiency of the proposed
new dwelling is laundable but simply not
truly outstanding or exceptional in
quality
highly energy efficient buildings carbon
neutral buildings and autonomous homes
are nothing new
in fact they are more common than you
would think especially with self
builders and hopefully this will become
the norm
in the
opinion of the town council the energy
efficiency of the proposed dwelling does
not in itself justify development in the
countryside
to approve this application would set a
dangerous precedent to open the
floodgates or similarly energy efficient
homes to be built in the countryside
outside the development
boundaries and contrary to policies
um
as10
and
of the um
nppf
30 seconds another call strategy sorry
and uh ndp policies h5 b1 and b2
marvis thank you very much for within
the time members do we have any
questions for council downing please
council mills
good to see you good to see you um you
said it's um how far is it from the town
center one question
so how far is that
for the crowd sorry it's about a mile
and a half is it right exactly on the
crest of bournemill
and i mean um i
you say you it's it's not exceptional
the um
the green credentials
um
and but according to the world members
you said it is a fantastic looking
building or so
what why why do you think is not
exceptional
well we don't think it's exceptional um
there are several uh examples very close
of exceptional houses that have been
built in the countryside but it's just
our opinion this isn't
okay any other stretch power
any other questions
no in that case council darling thank
you very much your time and patience and
of course your contribution um our next
week on this item is mr phil shepherd
our architects mr sheppard would you
like to come forward
so once again you'll have three minutes
30 second warning whenever you're
settled and comfortable the floor is
yours
okay good evening
we're at a
pivotal point in time where we have a
housing crisis energy crisis and climate
crisis
it takes on average 50 tons of carbon
dioxide to build a new brick and block
house in the uk
to put that into context the room we're
sat in today
it would fill with one ton
of carbon dioxide each new house emits
50 of these rooms in its construction
that's the embodied carbon of the house
then we consider the operational carbon
if we used the new houses at gaydon and
bishopton
lane as an example
there are new gas boilers
they would emit
200 000 tons of co2 over the next 20
years through their operational carbon
our house is the complete opposite
it removes
30 tons or 30 rooms
of this scale from the atmosphere
in its production of its prefabricated
straw bale walls
timber roof
timber wall cladding
our house will absorb more carbon than
it emits
every material has been carefully
selected
to absorb carbon or reduce its carbon
impact
we have worked with the contours of the
site to reduce the need for concrete
foundations by working with the slope
rather than against it
we will use recycled screw piles to
support the house and these allow us to
retain all of the existing trees
hedgerows
and allow us the opportunity
to increase the number of trees
plant new hedgerows to the southern
boundary and significantly enhance the
biodiversity of the site
our house is zero carbon in operation
it uses ground source heating solar
panels
excellent air tightness and passive
house levels of firmware performance
to deliver an exceptionally low energy
house
this is the next level of sustainability
and what it takes to become carbon
neutral by 2030 this is by no means
business as usual
if i were to cycle from here tonight to
the site it would take me seven minutes
four minutes faster than to the urban
extension to the north of stratford we
have schools doctors within 700 metres
of our site
the proposal before you is aspirational
30 seconds and is a result of a year's
worth of research collaboration and a
testing of ideas of an independent panel
of experts who have confidently endorsed
the design as exceptional
three years ago the council declared a
climate emergency
with the aim of being carbon neutral by
in the district by 2030
as our leaders you have the opportunity
to support a scheme that you can hold
others to account against
we need to act now
we need to find another way to meet our
collective goals
and our aim is to signpost it with the
design of this house
thank you
thank you very much indeed members do we
have any questions architect council
adam please
thank you um
i think the
the approach to reducing carbon is
laudable um the the other requirement
though i think that seems to be
in question about making it exceptional
um seems to be how it would
significantly enhance its immediate
settings um can you just elaborate on
why you think you would do that outside
of just the the aspects that you've
spoken about absolutely so
in terms of the visual appearance of the
the scheme um it's been
specifically located towards the bottom
of the site to protect long views from
borden hill
so the garage block you'll see on that
picture with the green roof
is set below the level of the public
footpath so when you're the long view
from borden hill was fantastic across
stratford you see the rsc tower
the house doesn't block that important
view um
and also they did landscape design we're
boarded by
woodland
which we've brought that into the site
so we across the boundary blurring the
boundary between the woodland and our
landscape design
and to basically just try and nestle the
house down into the site and a very
specific landscape design in terms of
its trees its flora fauna fauna
there's a wetland pond which deals with
the rain water so we're trying to deal
with absolutely everything on our on our
site
um
with
no kind of impact on anyone else
hopefully that answers you thank you
very much indeed and do we have any
other questions for our
answer crumb very briefly um
to talk about the design of exceptional
quality and you've touched on most three
things in the answers against the adams
question
just a bit i want some reassurance about
significantly enhance its immediate
setting after you talked about the views
of just how how we enhance the immediate
setting please so the the immediate
well the
existing site is overgrown
has been for a long long time
bordered by by trees
the
the sighting that as i said before has
been very
tested with
design midlands to design a view panel
and we've had three
design reviews where that question is
constantly asked through the review
panel to see if it passes the test of
paragraph 80. so paragraph 80
has a number of criteria on which to to
judge exceptional design
and whilst this is with local policy as
10 j
the views taken that we use paragraph 80
of the mppf to
to set that test and what are those
goals
obviously design is subjective so the
mppf recommends we use design review
panels
and having gone through that that
process with the with the panel
on three occasions that the design of
the house has evolved
um to to the point now where
i think we're very very confident that
it's an improvement to this site the
landscape enhancement the character that
that takes on so the the woodland that's
there at the moment the hedgerows
become enhanced by the landscape design
anyone else
can smells
thanks thanks for cheering me up i've
got these my little notes down here i
think it's all been answered i said is
it now exceptional design and you think
it is
um
i'm saying can this can this be seen by
neighbours
you say it's settled in
you can
prob rooftops most likely because of the
the fall of the site falls away from
beaconwood which is the existing
dwelling at the top um there's a
significant fault about five meters
across the top so as you walking down
the public footpath uh to the
um to the east
sorry the west um
you will get glimpses through the
existing hedgerow but the existing
hedgerow is mature will will be enhanced
and it's it's glimpse views so it's not
this isn't the house that's there to
stand and say look at me you know on our
glossy glitzy it's a house that will
weather so
consciously clad it and see see the
shingles which will silver down pick up
the tones of the woodland the hedgerows
the landscape
that's the intent and for me and
the trees are to be retained
yeah absolutely so that was one of the
key decisions um we made for the first
decision we retain everything
um i'm using the screw pile technology
um basically as you can imagine just
looks like a giant version of a screw um
and they're literally screwed into the
ground and they anchor so you can
put them very close to trees um
without harming those trees at all so
it's um we tried to
you know what one of the previous
paragraph 79 before we talked about
innovative
so screw piles were that kind of next
step forward
um and trying to
not use concrete
which is very bad for in body carbon
thank you very much
and last chance members any questions no
that was fascinating thank you very much
indeed for your time and patience this
evening
okay we have no further speakers in this
item does anyone have any questions
they'd like to put it to our offices
council dixon
hi chairman um exceptional design
obviously by
environmental aspects do we have any uh
images of the elevations of this uh
potential property
i do have some sort of cgi images which
i can share with you so if you just bear
with me while i get those up
while you bring those up i'm going to
see if anyone else has anything they
would like to clarify no in that case
once they're up we'll move into the
debate
so i'll just go
through this document there's quite a
few so this is this is obviously the
view um
from the access so this is the um
the garage
office area which
is obviously to be sunken into the
landscape and then you have the um
the main part of the development then um
which is um you can see um which will
obviously be the screw piles
so i'll just go through this some of
these images are very similar so i'll
just scroll through these ones quickly
and then these are um
some images so this is the proposed view
from the bottom of the north eastern
footpath
so the building
you can be seen there
and this one is a midway along the north
eastern footpath looking into the site
um this one is
within the site with the new boundary
hedging to the garden boundary to the
left-hand side
and this is looking back up towards the
house from the rear
and now this is the proposed view from
the northwest footpath looking back
towards the scheme
through the existing hedgerow
and that's in a winter more of a winter
context for you
thank you amy you're welcome marvelous
amy thank you very much okay let's move
into our debate
councillor jennings please
okay
first thing springs to mind here is wow
um
negative carbon dwelling
um it's got all the satisfies all the
green conden credentials zero carbon
there's even going to be a bit of sill
money in there
and
very rarely no trees will be harmed in
the making of this building
um
in my view this this application is an
exceptional design that satisfies all
the requirements of paragraph 80 and i'm
more than happy to propose uh that we
grant this application
thank you very much councilman mills
next please yeah thanks mr um yeah it's
quite incredible isn't it and what um
matt was saying uh absolutely right it's
just an exceptional building i think the
the question was um
is where it's cited i don't i don't
think anybody disagrees um
the world members he said it is a
fantastic building so
i'm happy to second uh councillor
jennings um proposal thank you mr
chairman thank you very much counselor
edwin next please
echoing what everyone else has said
before this is
sensational it sets the bar as we're
exactly where we should be so they beat
you to the punch but
it's sensational
not just exceptional cancer kendall did
you indicate
it's all been said
thank you councillor adam first please
thank you um yeah i do agree i think it
is it does hold up to be um
very high quality and architectural
design i think it's just worth noting
out that the concerns were
that the green credentials weren't
enough on their own let's say i think
that chat that has been met with this
um and i think it was just worth sort of
verbalizing that because
you know that that seemed to be put
forward as the argument by by the um the
architect i think actually the design
does go beyond that to meet the
credentials that we require it to and so
i'm happy to support thank you council
family
and with my other hat on and vice chair
of our climate change panel this is what
we're aiming for
um i think these are the kind of
buildings that we need that'll help us
meet the targets that we've set
and uh and i would support everything
that anyone else has said and that we
should be actually looking to get this
sort of building done
so i would i'm gonna be supporting the
action
thank you very much um short for us and
what everyone already said developers
take note this is wonderful this is what
we're looking for uh let's go for a vote
so the proposal is to grant in line with
office recommendation we'll have a show
of hands for those in favor
uh that is unanimous the committee
resolves to grant application 21 0 3 7 6
3 ful fabulous now it is 20 it is 8 26
we will at the very minimum be starting
our next item however as you all know
within line with the constitution if we
haven't started our final item before
half past eight
we will be finishing after the next item
we do however have discretion if we want
to carry on we have two items left
we have six minutes of speakers on each
i'm quite happy to carry on and we'll
propose that we do i'm also quite happy
for someone to propose that we do the
opposite if we had a lot more of these
i'd be very i'd have a very different
view but because i think it's something
relatively quick i'm prepared to carry
on going forward you have to second
could have a quick show of hands at all
those in favor
right that's unanimous marvelous thank
you very much everyone okay so our next
application is 2200 715 ful newlands
loxley lane in wellsborne our presenting
officer is paul
thompson sorry i've just flipped to
melina there thank you again
paul over to you thank you very much uh
i'll make it as quick as i can we are in
wells born by the airfield on newlands
caravan site which is the black dot
yonder
this is what it looks like a bit closer
in as you can see we're focusing in are
they shared because i can't see oh i beg
your pardon
so
keen to get on with it though
how about that
right so
yeah wells born airfields we got that
part um this is the part of the site
we're looking at towards the north
western corner uh there's a public right
of way indicated in the green
and that's not really a factor in this
determination which it's a bit closer
and again as you can see the access goes
through the site
up to northwestern corner you can see on
this plan as well that there are uh
containers there in the southeastern
corner there are caravans uh across the
site both stored and for occupation as
well as that uh existing storage
container use
down there and it's been a caravan site
for about 20 years now i believe if not
more and
the um storage use was granted on appeal
in 2009
[Music]
it's just a bit of visual excitement to
make sure you're still awake
there we go that's how it looks a bit
closer in and you can see there's an
earth earthen bund
uh bank uh between the main part of the
site that we're looking at which is here
and a small part of it that will extend
into the caravan storage
here
and that's what it's going to look like
afterwards largely the same less of a
bund more containers
they look like that
uh
here's the some photographic evidence uh
that's looking towards the
across a couple of caravan pictures
towards caravan storage which is the
other side of the the bond with the
hedge there
looking straight towards the siding of
the containers there they'll be lined up
pretty much against the armco with the
planting to the rear and then that is
looking north towards the sort of denser
vegetation
on the northern boundary of the site uh
sure my recommendation is that we grant
planning commission for this development
paul thank you very much indeed let's
call our first speak for the item as
councillor and prior from wellsborne and
walton the parish council good evening
and welcome thank you so much for your
patience it's been a long evening for us
all i think
so i think you've got a general gist
you'll have three minutes i'll give you
a 30 second warning as soon as you i can
see that my friend's on so as soon as
you're ready i have to say it's not the
first time i've been at the end of a
meeting well small seems to always end
up at the end of the agenda
it's not deliberate i can assure you but
yeah whenever you're ready
i was born in walton parish council
objectives application as we unlike the
officers believe that an additional 20
storage containers will have a
detrimental impact on the landscape
around the site turning an open green
space into an industrial site
a detrimental impact that has actually
increased over the years
when the original application was for 20
storage units which was made in 2010 we
objected to that on the grounds it was
an application making a rural site an
industrial area and that this was not a
suitable development
the refusal of that application by
stratfor district council was then
overturned on appeal
what we feared then would happen has
indeed happened in incremental ways over
the succeeding years
in 2016 a further 50 containers were
granted upon application by the owners
again we objected to this application
now a further 20 containers
if this is granted there will be 90
storage containers situated in the
middle of a rural area disrupting
further the wildlife corridors from
increased movement on and off the site
the allied increased noise levels and
increased industrial activity
we're always told when we're looking at
planning applications that we have to
comment on the application before us and
that we cannot look at what might happen
however the fears that we had and
expressed in relation to previous
applications have been realized what we
have here is increasing
industrialization of a rural area with
little care for the environment and the
surrounding area and for those reasons
the parish council would ask that you
refuse this application
council brian thank you very much do you
have any questions for councillor
council curtis
very much just just very quickly um i
think you mentioned increased traffic
movements do you have any indication of
the number of traffic movements that
might be associated with this increased
usage
we haven't got definite figures but this
um
site is off a very narrow road which is
increasingly used by access to the
airfield and is also a rat run to get
around to stratford too so it's a very
busy road we haven't got the figures for
the access and egress to the site no
council crap
very briefly so going from 70 to 90
units on the site is that right
roughly 30 increase
okay thank you
okay anymore for any more no in that
case cancer prices thank you very much
for your time and patience thank you
okay let's move to our next speaker on
this item is council councillor
you've got a promotion uh it's mr andrew
murphy um
i think you know the the drill three
minutes 30 second warning when you're
ready thank you chairman
newlands caravan park is a major
commercial storage site with 42 pictures
of touring caravans 400 pitches for
caravan storage and 70 self-contained
storage units in shipping containers
the business was started in the 1990s
and has grown steadily for 25 years
the site contains over 5 million pounds
worth of assets
due to the high standard of security the
site has the benefit of a gold award
issued by the caravan storage site
owners association
this is a rare award the nearest gold
award being at nuneaton
and the award is one of the reasons why
there is such a high demand for storage
at newlands
there is only one objector wells born
parish council
and they object on the grounds of loss
of green space harm to wildlife
increased activity and noise
this objection displays a fundamental
misunderstanding about the proposal
the proposal involves replacing caravan
storage with ship with 20 shipping
containers
so one stop one type of storage will be
replaced with another
the site boundary is not increasing
there is existing hard standing
and there is no impact on wildlife
because there is no wildlife on the site
given the caravans will be replaced with
container storage there will not be an
increase in traffic or a change to the
character and appearance of the area
the site has a strong landscape belt on
its boundaries
and the proposed containers will not be
visible from outside the site
furthermore the containers measure only
two and a half meters tall and will
replace caravans of similar mass and
height
finally the proposal supports an
existing rural business with a proven
track record of offering a high standard
of commercial storage in a secure
environment
the site is close to local households
and local businesses such as wellsborne
market who are in need of storage
therefore i ask you to support the
office of recommendation and grant
planning permission thank you mr murphy
thank you very much dude members do you
have any questions for our agent
councillor curtis please thank you very
much and
you mentioned that the the local market
might use storage local i was i'm just
interested to know what what these um
units would be used to store generally
well the applicant thinks that uh the
trade as a well market would want to
store their their items in there uh you
know for long periods so in other words
when
drawing the trading periods they'll be
trading wellsborne airfield and other
times they'll be uh storing it in the
storage units
okay unless we've got any other
questions which is anything we have mr
murphy thank you very much for your time
and patience
okay no further speakers on this item so
have we got any points clarification to
our offices
no let's move to debate who would like
to kick us off counselor jenny
when i used to live in birmingham i used
to have one of these
uh one of the containers well hired one
and it was
incredibly useful because houses tend to
be smaller than
than the than what you want them to be
and you do need storage
um i think the
the argument about the additional visual
impact
well it's already happened um and you're
just replacing one
object with another um
i can't see any material planning so
again
material planning reasons to go against
the officer's recommendation here and
i'm going to go straight in there and
recommend that we grant planning
permission on this
thank you very much i've seen no one
else raise a hand so i'll come in and
second that um
i'm pleased to note that there is
condition to make sure these are in fact
dark green i would have certainly
insisted on one otherwise
but i can see no other planning reason
why i would go against it so i will be
seconding does anyone else want to say
anything about us no in that case let's
go to a vote proposal is to grant in
line with offers a recommendation could
have a share of hands please
application application 2200 715 ful at
newlands locks lane in wellspawn okay
our final item of the evening is
application 2200
245 fuel that is bridge barn in
birmington our presenting officer is
marwina ichik
welcome good evening and thank you for
your patience too
whenever you're settled and ready to go
the floor is yours
good evening um thank you german
so um the application site uh is denoted
by a black dot on on the plan displayed
the application side is located in the
parish of
birmington at the south of the main
settlement
and this is the outline
here on this plan you can see
[Music]
the residential dwelling converted barn
and the existing detached garage
and
the site has one neighboring property to
the south and
[Music]
the site is also um also lies within
cotswolds fringe a special landscape
area and parts of the site lies within
flood zones
3 2 and 1
however the proposals are not within the
flood zones
um
um on this plan
you can see
on the left hand side the existing side
plan
and on the right hand side the proposed
site plan
and
planning permission is sold for a single
story extension
to link the side of the front of the
existing dwelling here
with the side of the existing garage so
this is the exis the proposed link
extension here
with the doorway facing the highway
it is also proposed to part convert the
ground floor of the existing garage
um
on the next slide on the left hand side
you can see the existing floor plumb
and the other in in the existing
elevations
and on the right hand side you can see
the proposed floor plan
um
and the elevations
the total floor area of the proposed
extension
would be nearly 10 square meters
the extension's width and depth would be
3.6 meter per 2.6 meter
and the maximum height would be 2.9
meter
and
i do apologize there was an error in
in the officer um report um
that was uh
corrected in the circulated update sheet
um
basically uh in my report i stated that
the extension would be larger but in
fact what is proposed is smaller
and
i will now show you some photos of this
side
so
um
here you can see um
the vehicle or access to this side
and the courtyard this is the
the existing garage and um
at the back this is the existing
dwelling
uh here is um
on this photo
you can see the carriage and again the
dwelling at the back
the proposed extension would fill this
gap between the side of the carriage
and
this part of the main house
and on this photo you can see
um
the approach to the site from
um
a34
100
that is here
and
the grass verge
thank you
chairman the recommendation is to
approve the application for planning
permission subject to the conditions as
detailed within the committee report
thank you thank you very much indeed um
let's call our first speaker on this
item who is councillor dawn fisher of
birmington parish council or parish
meeting i should say
forgive me gotta get that right
you can use whichever one you like and
whichever one you're comfortable at um
you've got an idea of the the remit now
it's three minutes 30 second warning
when you're ready and comfortable feel
free to start
i have got some slides haven't i've got
some slides
now will you give us notification when
you want to move on slides uh yeah yes i
can i think it'll be quite obvious
actually yes it's always helpful because
yes it's obvious definitely obvious to
you but it's not always obvious to us
i'm putting the first page in the second
page and i think i'm actually saying it
so okay
okay that's good okay so whenever you're
ready
i am representing birmingham parish
meeting who object to this
uh on proposal of the new doorway onto
the highway willington road on safety
grounds
the phot these photographs are intended
to put the following facts into context
the first series that you'll see you can
see now show a car parked on the highway
adjacent to the proposed doorway there
are two obvious points to make you can
clearly see how difficult it is to pass
the stationary vehicle
all overtaking vehicles have to drive
over the opposite verge
delivery vehicles are generally
considerably larger than a car
it is highly likely visiting traffic
will drive onto the grass where it is
safer for the traffic but is it safer
for pedestrians and horse riders
that verge an area of approximately one
meter by six meters will clearly be
eroded over a relatively short time
the second page
of photographs shows the approach from
the north
where the road follows a long right hand
bend
giving limited visibility before it
opens to a fairly steep descent towards
the a3400 where everything automatically
gathers momentum and the final
photographs
show the current main entrance to bridge
barn
there is more than adequate room for
delivery vehicles to pull in off the
highway
it is inconceivable that one would
assume a delivery vehicle will park at
the main entrance and walk to the
proposed new entrance
if it is imperative to have a pedestrian
access there is plenty of space to the
left of the main gates
this lane although narrow is
surprisingly busy and populated by
pedestrians horse riders and cyclists to
heavy goods vehicles and agricultural
vehicles
it services a public footpath and bridal
way and there is no pavement there are
no lay bys and very limited grass verge
in places it is also part of a national
cycle route number 48 and recent
revisions have been made to the highway
code in favor of pedestrian cyclists and
horse riders whereby vehicles have to
give 1.5 to 2 meters of space at least
when overtaking
how has how has that been allowed for in
this decision in 30 seconds more often
than not large vehicles choose to travel
this road to a via to avoid driving
through the village of birmington which
is often rendered impassable to hgvs and
agricultural vehicles due to residents
and visitors parking on the highway
because they have no choice
we are using our local knowledge to
bring these safety issues to your
attention
factors that do not always show up on a
map drawing or screen
thank you
marvelous thank you very much councillor
fischer members do we have any questions
for our counsellor please
no you do castlemails
thanks richard good evening um i i did
go and visit the site and um i didn't
see any cars parked uh outside there at
the time but it is your main concern
that that the new
uh link
is going to be
a doorway it's the doorway that's the
concern
the doorway coming out onto the highway
is the concern it's not the link itself
that's fine it's the actual new doorway
the pedestrian doorway that's going to
be
created
when we feel that if you want a
pedestrian access there's plenty of
space by the main gates
thank
you okay if there are other questions
no cancer thank you very much for your
time contribution and of course your
patience this evening
okay our final speaker of tonight is mr
murphy again
once again you'll have three minutes 30
second warning once you're settled the
time is yours
thank you chairman
the proposed development involves the
construction of a small link between the
modern garage block block and the barn
conversion
the link will consist of a screen wall
and a door on the roadside and a glazed
elevation on the courtyard side
it will have very little impact on the
character of the barn conversion
part g of the development requirements
spd allows for lean-to extensions to
barn conversions and so there should be
no objection in principle
the upper floor of the garage is
currently used as guest accommodation
and a home office
the link provides an energy efficient
and convenient access between the two
buildings
the link also serves as a hall which is
lacking in the barn conversion
the hall will provide more security than
the current arrangements
whereby visitors must enter via the
courtyard and the ground floor of the
barn conversion is heavily glazed and
open plan
birmington parish meeting has objected
on the grounds of harm to highway safety
i must clarify that no vehicular access
is proposed
because of the traditional form of the
barn conversion with its blank roadside
elevations
it has no direct street access for
pedestrians
the proposed roadside door and letterbox
embedded in the link
will provide a safe and convenient place
for people making deliveries
the committee report correctly points
out that it is possible to park safely
in front of the existing access
and they'll and then walk along the two
meter wide grass verge to the proposed
link
there are good forward visibility sight
lines and congestion or obstruction on
the road caused solely by the pedestrian
door is unlikely
county highways has no objection to the
proposal
therefore i recommend that planning
permission is granted thank you
thank you very much ms murphy any
questions members council curtis
yes just
a bit of clarification really um
what is the purpose of this door
the purpose of the door is
to make it more convenient for people to
drop off deliveries so at the moment
uh to to to be able to get into the
house you've got to go through the the
existing vehicular access and then into
the courtyard
and then you've got to go to the front
door the barn conversion which is
heavily glazed and it's all open plan
the household have a lot of deliveries
so rather than having delivery vehicles
just drive
through into the courtyard it's more
convenient for them simply to park at
the roadside and use this front this
door as a front door basically
to drop off deliveries
so it's more convenient in that respect
for
delivery drivers to simply park at the
vehicular access and then just go into
the into this new door thank you
council mills
thank you so
in the past then uh they've driven into
the the courtyard and not given a
problem but there are gates there yeah
so sort of yeah
the gates open and then they can drive
in
and then go to the
glazed part of the barn but that's never
been a problem in the past well it's a
problem to the household because they
they they feel that it's not safe to do
so because i believe there's a housewife
there most of the day
because there's no hallway that the
delivery drivers are literally going to
the glazed elevation of the barn
conversion and making their delivery
there
so the household feel that it's safe and
more convenient for delivery drivers to
to use this proposed door
which is fronting the highway
thank you
any further questions council fleming
when you say the householders have a lot
of deliveries is this a commercial
business or is it just a private is just
a private dwelling house
okay let's just do a lot of shopping
okay thank you
all right for some um anyone else your
counseling
oh yes um
do the owners own the grass verge in
front of the front door as you proposed
as far as i'm aware no they don't it's
part of the highway it's the highway
perch okay thank you
okay last chance anyone else
no
mr murphy thank you very much for your
time contribution and patience this
evening we have no more speakers so
points of clarification to our officers
would anyone like to ask our officers
any questions
no
let's kick off and debate who would like
to start us off councillor crumb
i'll give cancer change the rest so i'll
open the button this time um
obviously i've concerns about road
safety i often receive communications
that a road is an accident waiting to
happen
um
what i'm concerned about is that the
highways agency is the authority
that looks after highways road safety
etc and there's no objection on their
behalf
and i've not seen any strong evidence
for us to go against the highways
authority to say that um
it's unsafe
so
um
i will propose that we go with the
officer recommendation on this one
thank you very much council jennings i
saw your hand go up
i was gonna say pretty much the same
thing i mean we have to base our
decisions on material planning matters
um
there's no objections from highways
so we have to go with the experts
opinion on this so i'm happy to
second the proposal
marvellous thank you very much anyone
else wants to make any contributions in
the debate
council curtis
i hear what's being said but i think
delivery drive is going to pull up
outside that door and create an
obstruction
i think i agree with you but
unfortunately we don't control them the
highway code is there for a reasonable
does say do not block road
it's up to them whether they obey that
and it needs to be enforced and that's
down to the police i'm afraid not us
we're here to talk about planning
matters
casa mills i am patrick hodgson hook i'm
more or less going to say say the same
thing um when i first looked at this
application i thought oh gosh you know i
thought
i can't say anything wrong but now i can
um
in my mind
the blocking of that road would be a
problem with with the large vehicles i
still can't understand why they i know
we're not here to look at it at this uh
but i can't understand why they still
can't drive into the um
into the courtyard but uh that's not
what's in front of us but thank you
casa vixen
i can see let's see delivery drip
vehicles not pulling up at that doorway
because there is an immediate
entrance to the drive
very shortly thereafter a few paces back
to that door even if they use that one
they don't need to go into the courtyard
that drive away you can go down that
road and slightly pull in i think that's
fine i think these photographs showed
that
you're a better sensible delivery man
than the ones that delivered to my house
i can assure you okay look we've got a
proposal uh it has been seconded um i
think we should go to the vote now so
the proposal is to grant in line with
the office of recommendation could i
have a show of hands for those in favor
please
eight eight and those against
three and abstentions
no one okay marvelous in that case uh
committee resolves to grant uh
application twenty two zero zero two
four five ful is bridge barn in
birmington
uh members um amendment officers people
in the
in our public gallery thank you so much
for your time contribution this evening
and we'll see in a couple of weeks thank
you very much
that was
knackering